O well hey everybody what's going on
it's too bright right no it's not too
bright I think it looks good yeah I
think it's too bright I don't have my
hat jeez all this [__] I my [__] bald
ass hat and like I don't have my hat get
in bit well if you weren't in the other
room like farting around with that porn
site then yeah fix then you would have
been here on time yeah we're having a
problem in the other [__] room with
some porn
sight [__] the controls never [__]
appear on a thing it's got to be
something the problem with the browsers
I'm sitting there trying to figure out
what's wrong with my [__] Xbox one
yeah it's got to be browsers or
something it probably is I got to have
my I we got to have our porn on
demand I'm going to get my hat he's
going to go get his let get my hat I got
my underwear on hold on see that [__]
see that [__] so early I got my
[__] got sexual [__] out on
here
uhhuh all right Qui get
TR H Zach says perfect timing literally
just sat down for dinner and this yes
Zach gave us the idea for the show which
thank you for doing that because I do
not think uh that I would have come up
with that uh on my own maybe I would
have but it probably would have taken a
long time but it's actually like a
really good topic because unlike many of
you youngsters on this show I not only
remember when Princess Diana died I
remember when Princess Diana and Prince
Charles got married that's how [__]
old I am yeah I remember all that when
like was a kid but I remember it being a
big [__] deal and I remember like
clips of the I didn't watch the wedding
but I remember CU I wasn't really into
the royal family but um but I remember
clips that would being all over the news
and stuff like on TV all the time yeah
Leslie says Jenny show us she we
panties Min skirt on I actually don't
have any on right now well you know what
I mean we were doing streamate earlier
yeah so and Tom decided he was just
going to stay he just going to stay in
the
outfit I stayed in the outfit I stayed
in the outfit too but I just put a shirt
on over it because it was a little much
it was a little much I thought so you
know what I mean Jen's waist is looking
like this now hey today I got into a
corset that I've not been able to get
into for many many years show them show
many many
years why you got to make me get up all
the time I get all comfortable pull your
SK down because the coming out well I
well that's okay yeah see that one that
one that one back up over here damn it
please stop I just got look at it you do
so so they can see see they see your
silhouette yeah okay let's
go now I got to like squish down in
chair
again he always makes me get up and move
around after I'm done getting up and
moving around she wants to fold up in
there well yeah that's it's not
comfortable to just sit with my feet on
the floor I have to cross cuz I'm
short yeah John said uh her wedding
dress was like a city block long yeah it
was a big I mean it was that was like
80s it of cuz I had forgotten what it
looked like and then I was like watching
documentaries about this and I'm like oh
my God I forgot how [__] ugly that
wedding dress was but I guess like
everybody thought it was pretty in the
80s because in the 80s everything had to
be more like it had the big puff sleeves
and like the big huge train and all that
kind of [__] but uh yeah High Desert
said people got up early to watch that
wedding nonsense I remember that I
remember everybody like I said I didn't
but yeah because it happened kind of was
it in the middle of the night I don't
even remember
but um yeah a lot of people got up to
watch that and I remember people talking
about it at school what was funny is
that there was so much of that [__] when
I was a kid so much of that [__] on on
on television this royal wedding and
princess die you had so these dumbass
American kids I went to school with that
thought that that was our princess they
didn't realize that that was like
another country was [__] England you
know you had to straighten that out you
know with a lot of them for some reason
they thought that that was had something
to do with the United States that's some
British [__] man I mean the I will say
uh
Diana actually did seem and from
everybody that knew her and stuff like
that just like a lovely delightful human
being which is unusual for the royal
family uh which is probably why none of
them liked her yeah because she was
actually I was watching uh there was a
buzzfeed unsolved about this about like
all the conspiracy theories about her
death and stuff which is what we're
talking about um and they said one of
them said something really funny they
said yeah it's little it's a little
indicative of like how shitty the royal
family is is because she was like nice
and compassionate and they were all like
suspicious and hated her yeah and I'm
like yeah that tracks that's that's
about right yeah you know do I think
they killed her no I don't think they
killed her oh you ruined the show no I'm
just saying there's a lot of
conspiracies there are but I don't think
they killed her I don't know enough
about it I think it's unlikely yeah um
I'm not saying I had to hear more I mean
maybe but I I had to hear more of these
things before I can make a decision but
they wouldn't have to why would they
have to they wouldn't have to kill
anybody but you know that's what
conspiracy theories are going to come up
with reasons of why that she was [__]
pregnant with jodz or something you know
[__] [__] like that I don't know prob
no I don't think so I mean it would it
seemed like I mean I don't know we'll
get into it I there are a couple of okay
maybe one legitimate reason maybe like
why they did something but but I don't I
don't know I I don't think it's not
enough for me I'm not and you know and
I'm not saying that's not what happened
because I don't know but I'm just saying
that it's it's not enough for me it's
not enough evidence you know what I'm
saying yeah but we'll get into that and
there a lot of British people are saying
well we shouldn't have a royal family
that that just
oldfashioned democracies don't have that
[__] blah blah blah republics and
everything but you look at the United
States man
[__] this is more like a [__]
plutocracy or an old oligarchy anyway so
we might as well have Royal people it's
about the it's about the same about the
same [__] thing call them oligs it's
equally shitty yeah equally yeah well
the it's the highest form of organized
crime it starts off as a mafia that
takes over the land and then they become
a ficial and then they're known as kings
and dukes and they still run it like a
mafia basically well that's what an
oligarch is it's just a [__] Mafia
well it's just people with all the
[__] money and they can always just
do whatever they want to the US
supposedly has a constitution that keeps
them off of you but they own the courts
they can do they own the courts he's too
dangerous you strange is I always got
the impression and I could be totally
wrong but just from what I know of their
legal systems in the UK even though they
do have a royal family one the royal
family doesn't have that much like
political power really they're kind of
like more figureheads I guess they do
have some but the constitution in the UK
I feel like and their legal system seems
a bit fairer than our
just in general just in general which is
interesting High Desert says old far
ocracy yeah I mean essentially that's
what happens if if there were any you
know a lot of the US Constitution was
kind of based on British common law was
what it was founded on the just
reinterpretation of things and it
actually some people say that that the
spirit of the of the American
Constitution at the time was kind of
like a reboot of the way small to Town
England would have been or you know that
was like based upon like that you know
um which it may be maybe I I don't know
I don't care because I don't think it's
a reality today um I think it's just
straight up patkin
Village um that's kind of worshiping
democracy which is a a failed God that
died but that it looks like it's alive
it's actually just an oligarchy
everybody you vote for is a servant they
serve the oligarchs that that's it
Republican and Democrat it's fake as
[__] fake like a pican village Zach says
The Surreal moment when Little Miss no
expression from Twilight got an Oscar
nom for playing Diana although I haven't
seen that movie but I heard she was
excellent in that and I yes I know she
was in Twilight but when she's in a good
movie she can actually act you know what
I mean and I think it was the same thing
that happened with Robert Patterson and
he just like shits all over that movie
which I think is hilarious it's like hey
it got it it got their foot in the door
they probably made all the money from it
and then after that they actually took
more interesting film roles and everyone
was like oh wow they can actually act
instead of just stand there looking all
vapid and sparkling and whatnot so I
mean she was in underwater and she was
great and like I said she did play Diana
but and I kind of wanted to see that but
I didn't see it she also played Joan Jet
in that movie about The Runaways which I
think was just called The Runaways they
haven't seen it I've seen it was it good
yeah I liked it a lot see it I um let's
see it was probably it was
before uh I saw it at my other at my ex
he wasn't really like an ex but my other
guy's house Mike and that's so that was
when me and Mike were going out okay cuz
I watched it at his house so 13 14 years
something like that yeah so it was like
right before we got together right but
um I liked it a lot but I haven't seen
it in that long so I don't know um and
then Z said something else oh back in
the 80s Charles and Diana visited the
set for a Bond movie I wonder if it was
View to a Kill because Diana was a big
Duran Duran fan probably and she was
because she would like always go see
them in concert and everything said and
she got to smash a sugar glass bottle
over his head I bet she really enjoyed
that yeah um that's the thing the way
that the wedding was portrayed I mean
they wanted it to be like oh it was this
big fairy tale and blahy blah
but I kind of feel like there were
problems even from the beginning one
they hadn't Charles and Diana hadn't
really known each other that long before
they got married it wasn't an arranged
marriage no one is saying that they
actually met at like a gathering or
whatever at like one of their hyy toyy
properties or whatever and they did seem
to hit it off and they did seem to like
kind of be sort of in love at first um
but from everything I heard I thought
Charles was banging that Camila Parker
bows chick like almost from the
beginning or before he even got married
and he like and he said some [__] like
they did an interview this is great well
it's not great it's awful but I'm just
saying there's a there was an interview
like not too long after Charles and
Diana got married and so the interviewer
asks them they're both standing there
it's like oh well something like you
guys are in love or something like that
and uh Danny's like well yeah of course
and Charles is like whatever love means
yeah and I was like bro
yeah why would you say that like because
everyone's gonna see that and she's just
standing there going those dudes grew up
[__] banging hookers from day one
from the best [__] esorts they just
they just saw women as women you know
yeah we yeah I love you babe okay look I
got to go back to my mistress yeah
[__] those dudes are ho they were
hounds and what's funny is he did end up
marrying that horseface camil yeah I was
going to say these are all ugly people
Diana wasn't though she was actually she
was I thought she was pretty I I call
she wasn't like beautiful or anything
but she was great I call that homely
which is you
know mediocre pretty you know kind of
like you you wouldn't pass up on her but
you know no no there's all kinds of just
stunning women that just blow her out of
the water there's something about that
class of people they're just ugly big
ears all that inbreeding
[__] Hatchet Face big nose [__]
Hawk nose [__]
[__] um lot of them they
probably real tall and skinny kind of
chinless Wonders over there particularly
the yeah they're ugly
yeah they marry each other they're just
[__] joining wealth together it
doesn't have anything to do with
breeding stronger children or better
looking people I'm gon to marry that
babe right there and have some Offspring
[__] oh she doesn't have nothing get
[__] out of here who who yeah I got but
you know they probably sire all kinds of
chicks or people out the wedlock that
aren't in the [__] family they
probably look great cuz they're all just
coming out of [__] girlfriends and
call girls and [__] concubines and
[__] they probably look a lot better the
uglier they are probably the more likely
they are that they're Royal oh yeah yeah
that comes out of that other [__]
royal snatch and this my snatch and the
snatch no too much in
breeding yeah High Desert said I always
wondered why di married that ass looking
Charles yeah and that was another thing
too it's like he always used to get on
her about it's like he would like grab
around the waist and go getting a bit
chubby here aren't we and then she got
bulimia and she like that like later on
and I was like look at you dude you have
no room to talk I'm sorry they're
mediocre looking like that [__]
Jesus mediocre yeah Tyler said by the
standards of where she was Diana was a
supermodel yeah she was a lot better
looking than any of them you know what
and she was from she was from
aristocracy too she wasn't just from
Rando don't don't for one second believe
that [__] there there aren't any
good-looking people in the UK man
[__] England's got some stunning
[__] girls and real good-looking guys
they're just they're just they're poor
though or middle
class I mean [__] we see call girls from
England all the time [__] streaming
with us those girls are [__]
Knockouts well that's what I mean Idol
was [__] I think one of the most
handsome guys to have ever [__]
walked the Earth really he should have
[__] bulked up some the girls [__]
loved him man and [__] I was a big
fan of Billy Idol and he you know he was
a poor dude from from England yeah know
well look at all the bands that came
from from there in the ' 80s that were
all like super [__] they were all
poor and good poor they had good
jeans cuz you got to mix them jeans up
jeans yeah they're too close together
like in the royal families you get
people looking like Prince charl well I
guess he's the king Now isn't he Ireland
Scotland Wales them
two I probably give it to [__] from
what I've seen [__] Scotland
though well you dated a Scottish girl
didn't you no I dated an Irish girl an
Irish girl that's right she was cute
though yeah but yeah her name is
Fiona yeah yeah she was from Court yeah
yeah I remember that she drink me on the
[__] table yeah I had to quit thas
impressed I had to quit
her I just can't take this
anymore [__] I go down and [__] go
she's like come on you Fanny yeah I try
I try to get I don't know if they say
that three cell phone times you didn't
you couldn't really just call somebody
on a cell phone only rich people had
cell phones I called her house [__]
phone had ring and I says that [__] is
at the bar cuz I knew I knew what uh bar
she hung out at she's Irish for Christ
yeah kind of what they kind of their
thing she's hanging out in an Irish pub
in Davis Square out in
Boston and uh I knew right where she'd
be and went down there and I'd see her
and she'd be just [__] loaded just
barely holding on [__] railings and
[__] almost underneath the table said
fion is just [__]
what you get me falling down drunk [__]
you just [__] like that yeah yeah yeah
[__] you oh my God I love stand the [__]
up you're falling down drunk oh [__] off
you know okay I kind of get like that
she was like that just [__] hold I
have to be pretty [__] drunk holding
on what the [__] wrong with
you yeah she was so [__]
up and I was like this [__] is Aly
man I got to move on so I stopped
showing
up she didn't seem to care though she
was like ah whatever there's other ones
yeah yeah
yeah there's other one Zach said Irish
people are the best looking out of the
UK if you ask me yeah I haven't seen
them all yeah well you know I mean I
spent a lot of time in Wales and some of
them were good-looking and some of just
kind of like here you know what I mean
it's like everywhere I've just noticed
there's a lot of good-look streammate
girls and a lot of good-look girls from
in the American porn industry that come
from England and and Australia too I
probably give it a little bit more to
Australia might be even a little bit
better looking
but anglo-americans Australians people
[__] the UK you know white people
from the UK we're all so similar you
know in we're you know inter related
from the same we're all basically the
same basic stock it's just you know if
you're from the south here you you might
have a little bit of a Native American
or Spanish in you somebody from the
Spanish Empire might be Ming in
there like I got [__] Spanish names
and French middle names in my [__]
name I don't going to tell you my whole
name my grandfather's name was bouar
yeah bouar Ross yeah yeah which is kind
of a crazy name when you think about it
yeah and there's a lot of guys named
Francis in in in in the family yeah yeah
as a first name yeah too yeah well that
wasn't that unusual back
then cuz I think I think now people
maybe think of it as do they think of
that as a women's name or just like a
unisex name also had weird think it
depends on the spelling it's usually if
you usually if it's a feminine name it's
spelled with es and then if it's a male
it's spelled with is yeah that's how
I've always seen it then another weird
Southern family member I had it was my
grandmother's cousin or Uncle I don't
remember his name was
Noah
Noah that's kind of that's kind of a
cool name actually it's a [__] wild
ass name to have not when you're just
walking around your name is Noah yeah
like that's right I'm going to build a
[__] boat I'm going to be the last
one out of all [__] Noah had
about two of every animal Noah had Noah
trained [__] cause he had about 5050
of
them was like a zoo behind his house
yeah that's awesome yeah one of them was
like over 100 years old huge maau and
they could talk they live a long time
yeah it could talk I always wanted one
but one the cats would hate it yeah and
two they live a long time and his wife
would go out there and work with him
every day and could teach him to sing
and they could sing full songs they were
all Bible
hymns that must been reallying singing
Jesus loves me and [__] like that and
they' sing it and [__] her name was
Dolly My Aunt Dolly and she would sing
it in Dolly's voice it sound like Dolly
singing it [__] bizarre see if we had
a maau it would just swear yeah probably
no these MAA [__] were
religious religious
MAA that's pretty funny yeah um she'd
get four or five of them singing
together that's cool yeah they'd singing
they all be singing the song Together
Tyler says Charles always kind of
reminded me of alfredy Newman yeah he's
got those big sticky outy ears and
you
know um we got listeners from the UK
they might explain why those [__] are
so ugly I told you it's in breeding even
Eddie aard said that AJ Vamp because
it's a bad idea when cousins marry
that's what he said that's why they all
look that way AJ AJ says they descended
from Transylvanian blood they descended
from counter they're all vampire and
they were basically all vampires I mean
he's joking when he says I mean that
would kind of explain a lot though yeah
well you know Vlad Vlad Prince Vlad was
he was he killed a bunch of boyars they
were they were Saxon or Anglo-Saxon
Merchants that had been
there in in vakia for centuries and
every been spread out all across and
I've heard that royal families in UK are
actually Saxons they're they're Germans
that kind of invaded and took over
hundreds of years ago so I don't
remember exactly like all the ins and
outs they might be a different ethnic
group slightly
yeah yeah Tammy says uh Killian Murphy
hot he is yeah um High Desert said I was
in love with Durand Duran too but they
sure haven't aged well you know what the
last time I saw them they actually
looked okay and I thought they were
holding out pretty well but I haven't
seen them in a long time those are old
too well yeah I mean they are quite old
but yeah I was a Simon girl big time
Nick's good too Nick was my second
choice everybody like when I was in
school when I this was Junior High
probably I was in junior high everyone
was all about John Taylor and I think
John Taylor was maybe my least favorite
well now maybe Andy was my least
favorite sorry Andy but um you know what
I mean he's not a Durand Durant anymore
but um oh Nick held out the best yeah
he's I thought he was still looking good
but like I said I haven't seen him in a
couple years I regret that I never got
to see them live that really sucked but
I remember that's because I remember
Princess Diana being like a huge fan of
Durand Duran because she went and saw
them at the what they um the princess
trust is that what they did they did
like big show every year like for um
charity and stuff Leslie said was she
really pregnant with the Arab and that
could have been the reason for her death
well that's one of the theories we'll
get into that yeah that's one of the
theories um like I said I'm not real
sure if I believe that either but we're
going to get into it and um yeah
somebody said that uh Dodie fiad it was
a flang yeah I think one okay so like I
said we're kind of like jumping ahead a
little bit but that's okay that's that's
just kind of what we do we're we just go
the way my brain works which is all over
the place so I what I think a lot of
people don't know maybe especially
people that kind of propound these sort
of like uh conspiracy theories about it
was that her and Dodie Fen were had
really only just started dating like a
month and a half ago it wasn't like some
big right like some big serious thing um
you know what I mean because there's you
know again it's a little teaser there
are some things it's like oh he was
going to ask her to marry him which
maybe he was I don't know because there
was a thing with the jeweler and he
bought a ring and [__] like that but
it's just kind of like I they don't know
if that's what that was for and they had
really only known each other for I think
it was 7 weeks which is like nothing you
know what I mean and it's like of those
seven weeks they probably could have
only hung out for maybe like three of
those weeks because of like the schedule
that they had you know cuz they were
pretty well accounted for like all that
time so it's not like they'd been
together for like years and years and it
was a thing they hadn't been together
that long somebody said that uh was it
Andy Taylor
yeah where T has terminal cancer didn't
know that oh [__] does he really now I'm
really sorry I know it yeah they were
all hot though you know what I mean they
were just like different like levels of
hot somebody said something about Steve
bashim you're a fan of Steve bashim yeah
I love
c um yeah John gor said watching Tales
from the Dark Side movie oh that's I
love that movie I don't I don't think
we've reviewed that yet have we I don't
think so it's an anthology I don't think
we you've seen it Debbie Harry's in it
yeah I thought we reviewed that I don't
think we reviewed it though Steve bashy
had sex appeal a ratty sketchy sex
appeal kind of like Steve baders or
Richard whitmark yeah it's just kind of
like and I'm kind of I'm kind of into
that that's like one of the things that
I kind of like he was popular with women
yeah there's something about it's not
he's not like goodlook like in the
classical sense but there's just
something about him you know what I mean
well I'd hit that he's kind of
interesting yeah I like interesting
people I like interesting looking or
interesting act like you know not compl
s fuckups there's also some something
about his there's also something about
his
voice his voice kind of lulls you kind
of kind of takes over he's kind of kind
of a soothing voice Zach says in William
defo too oh absolutely there's something
I think William defo is like actually
really sexy when he's doing villains
yeah yeah there's something really sexy
about [__] Goblin man [__] yeah
and uh is it kind is it [__] up that I
also thought he was kind of I don't know
you haven't seen it but is it also kind
of [__] up that I thought he was kind
of sexy and Antichrist I haven't seen it
and then it was also good y'all that
have seen it will probably no it's like
girl what are you you you were weird he
was great and as NS Fatu as Max Shrek
yeah in Shadow of the vampire vampire
yeah he's great in that I had seen that
he was so good well I kept telling you I
kept telling you it's like you have to
see this she'll love it she showed that
movie to me we reviewed it a couple
months back check it out the [__]
shadow of the vampire have you ever seen
the old it had John malovich and William
defo if you don't know I also think John
malovich is kind of sexy I'm real quick
here's the premise the original movie
about Dracula starred Max shreet it was
black and white silent fo it never got
released because they got hit for
copyright infringement and they [__]
destroyed the movie but only one copy
survived and people watch it it's a good
movie you can see it for free on YouTube
Max shrex plays Nas
feratu count orlock I think is what the
name that used right well in this movie
Shadow Of The Vampire it turns out that
when they made that
movie Nas Fatu Max Shrek really was a
vampire yeah like f mow found an actual
director found it so he it's the story
of making that
movie and that [__] dude playing a
vampire actually was a vampire and
promised that he would feed his leading
actress to him if he would do the movie
and a lot of the a lot of the co-star
the co-star didn't know right it was a
secret between him and the director oh
he's a method actor yeah he's a method
actor oh my God it's so good [__] I love
that [__] movie so much defo plays
and Eddie is AR plays the vampire man he
knocks it out of the park he looks
basically just like Max Shrek why did he
knock it a [__] Oscar for that that
was fantastic and he says some wild ass
[__] he was just so good yeah Camp guy
said William defo is supposed to have a
giant penis oh I never heard that
wouldn't surprise me he looks like a
dude that would have a giant
penis love th
guys yeah it's almost like well you
can't like bulk up with muscle so you
get something in compensation I guess I
don't know I don't know I'm just I'm
just like talking on my ass I don't know
man there's some
[__] that one dude in porn showed me
some of the other dudes that [__] are
out there [__] are monsters and
Bill showed me a dude that he shot with
his wife and he dude was from England
and he was about 63 and probably weighed
260 pounds of pure muscle and that
[__] was built like a damn 40 oz
beer can huge he and he's [__]
filming the scene with this big dude and
his little [__] 4 foot n wife that
weighs about about 80
pounds yeah oh and that dude was gay
yeah but he did a straight scene Victor
said skinny dudes are always hung as
[__] yeah I yeah yeah it's for some in
industry I've noticed that not really
sure why and I've heard it from a lot of
girls yeah that they'll kind of Target
skinny guys because they tend to have
bigger
dicks it might have something to do with
being an
ectomorph yeah a thin kind that
particular body style that particular
body style might carry jeans for that
but short guys
too uh [__] of any race I've noticed
that black guys short white guys there's
there's a tendency that some shit's
gonna
happen right I got video to prove it
you sitting there in your underwear
that's hilarious I
got Victor said thank you very much
Victor gave us a Super Chat Jenny did
you pull the reverse UNO card on Tom yet
I have not I have not man yall are
[__] nasty I know we're terrible yeah
we get people coming and asking for that
all the time [__] all the time and
I'm just like man we might have to do
this cuz people keep
asking one out of every six guys that
comes in there [__] starts homing in
on
yeah and giving me 20
questions but you got to be careful
because a lot of those dudes just want
they just want to talk right and they
want to dirty talk for free they just
keep asking you [__] insane questions
about what you do and what you don't do
and eventually you shut it down and say
we'll talk about it in private go hit
private button because then they got to
pay yeah $6.99 a minute right so you
know come on we'll we'll talk about that
yeah if you want to do it and then
because they they don't they're not into
spending any money yeah they're trying
to get you to do trying to get to talk
dirty to them [__] you got to watch
yeah they're trying to get you to talk
dirty to them gotta watch yeah but yeah
I'll talk dirty to you but you're gonna
pay I ain't no cheap
Corp expensive wh That's right that's
what we always say we're expensive hores
expensive
wh that old Camaro says go Tom rock that
Speedo he decided he told me earlier
he's like I'm just GNA wear I'm just
going to wear my [__] I'm just wear
wear my [__] his work clothes his
work clothes my work
clothes man it's the same thing it's the
same outfit [__] pro wrestler would
have on yeah it's not that it's not that
scandalous it just be like wrestlers
wrest scandalous yeah it's just he he's
like I'm just gonna yeah fck I was like
okay do it it' be funny I said probably
nobody would see it anyway but then then
he backs up enough to make sure
everybody sees it it's just
short
I said this is why I love you
Trump he just makes me laugh everying
single day wrest Weare got the boots and
everything hilarious got the boots and
everything or you can do like a pile
drive on me or something like later yeah
you never can't tell I mean you never
know we'll see oh my God we can't do it
here well no
obviously victure says this podcast has
been marked e for explicit yeah it's not
explicit well I mean here's the thing
though it's like I mean we get Dem it
gets limited and demonetized anyway we
don't make any money other than super
chats pretty much some of the old
episodes in the past yeah yeah yeah
because people still watch those and Stu
and some of that okay the last one that
we did that did that was okay was The
Wolf Man review because I don't think we
said any [__] up [__] on there yeah so
that one was all right but I think every
single one for like the past several
weeks before that was like limited ad
availability limited ad availability
[__] like that and [__] damn I was like
oh well what are you going to do what
are you going to do [__] YouTube I mean
yeah makes me wonder man we we got to be
we we ought to be [__] simultaneously
casting this also like on Rumble because
I heard that fing they don't [__]
demonetize you and you you can get paid
over there too well yeah they're more
like R-rated you can do R-rated over
there they're not trying to see
YouTube's
big and uh they pay the creators
well they don't want to pay the creators
so they'll find any excuse to
[__] [__] you out of your money well
our our [__] um what do you call them
our [__] sponsors don't want their
[__] to be on your [__] because you're
dirty man [__] that but get it cuz we
were talking about murders yeah yeah
yeah find some dirty spons [__] like
find some dirty see that's what I always
thought that's all you that's all you
got to do but it's like there's lots of
people out there that could advertise on
our [__] right find some sign find some
R-rated sponsors they don't do that
because it it makes more money for them
to say we're not going to pay you I mean
I could probably do that if I had time
yeah uh to find like some people that
would sponsor because that's kind of
what a lot of like horror creators and
stuff like that they usually end up like
pairing up with and they'll put an ad on
this we have to put the ad in well you
make your own ad make your own ad they
send you the info yeah they give you
like however much money it is um and
then uh you know you have to have so
many subscribers and [__] like that and
then they'll pay you like a set amount
for you to make like a little ad you
haven't seen that cuz I have some like I
some shows I watch they have sponsors
and they'll do like a little spot for it
yeah and they'll usually like send them
a sample of whatever it is cuz like one
girl I watched it's like she had one
sample that was like that mattress thing
and they sent her like a mattress yeah
and you know what I mean yeah and so she
was like showing it and all that other
kind of stuff but um you know like I
said I could probably do that but it
seems like a lot of the sponsors are
like kind of yeah
lame you know none of them are like fun
yeah why can't we get sponsored by like
a sex toy company like or like or
shutter or something like that it's too
dirty for YouTube I guess YouTube is
[__] like television nobody's
nobody's any fun come on the internet's
going out of style these old these old
internet platforms are going out of
style but uh but no we got confirmation
from Victor and uh all our other
gay uh following that yeah the skinny
dudes tend to tend to be humped yeah
yeah yeah I heard the same girlfriends
and [__] I mean it's been I you know I
don't know it's just kind of like in my
experience yeah that tends to be true
but I don't know I've seen I've seen all
shapes inside it may have something to
do with averages of ectomorph body
styles people that have an E with an
ectomorph is kind of tall and thin yeah
and um you know not super tall but just
kind of a thin build narrow shoulders
there may be something where that's also
associated with certain genes for size
yeah probably maybe I mean it could but
it's but or that could be just an
reinstate I [__] reiterate though
short guys though too and uh I don't
know if part of it is proportions if
you're shorter it look you look bigger
you know so proportion has a lot to the
same way you have short girls with tits
short girls have big tits well that
might actually only be a decup but she's
[__] little so 4 foot n right so it
looks on a taller woman that would be
like a triple E or a g or a double G you
know looking cup so it's like that U but
also you have to understand these short
little [__] that have survived
over time why were they
selected you know yeah why were they
selected to [__] have have Prodigy
well
they because they big boobs and big
digs yeah cu the females are also short
and SP being being
[__] brought to term by short breasty
women now short and breasty yeah now
that's going to be of course the ethnic
group the racial background is going to
matter there's a lot of little short
Japanese girls but they're flat you know
it's a different thing but you know when
it comes to white women
and black women really short ones tend
to be
built voluptuous you know well that's
certainly my case yeah and that's why
that's being [__] reinforced over and
over again that's that's a [__] I'm
also a short [__] yeah and
that's a popular
look for men men go for that so that's
being
reinforced I'm five for three on a good
day
mm but yeah so should we start talking
about about the actual topic now it's
time you think now that we've got we're
talking about the topic getting into the
meat and potato roundout let's start
talk let's start talking about the
conspiracy theories yeah I don't want to
get too much into because I think most
people know about like the marriage and
[__] like that but it's just like uh you
know what I mean and most people
probably know you know like I said the
death happened in 1997 I actually
remember it happening and it was very
shocking because it's like she's very
famous and she was only 36 when she died
I think her uh 36th birthday had been
like a month or so
before so and you don't really and
here's another thing I think the reason
why so many conspiracy theories popped
up was because she was so famous and I
mean she was like one of the most famous
people in the world at that time
recognizable all over the world and you
don't expect somebody that Larger than
Life to die in such kind of a stupid way
you know what I mean so I think that a
lot of people think oh well there had to
be more to it which like I said maybe
there was but maybe it was just a stupid
accident that you know that absolutely
could have been avoided but
unfortunately was not you know what I'm
saying so I do kind of feel like that
maybe fuels into it too that's why
there's so many conspiracy theories
about like any like really really famous
person that dies like in just in a dumb
like random way um because I think
people are like oh well they were just
Larger than Life they were more than a
person so for them to die in this stupid
way is not acceptable you know what I'm
saying yeah I kind of feel like there
there may be some aspect of
that so if uh so most people know
probably that she died uh August 31st
1997 and she died in Paris uh with uh
you know it was in a horrible car
accident there were three other people
in the car her boyfriend at the time
whose name was D fed um her uh the
driver hre Paul who was kind of a
bodyguard type well he worked at at the
Ritz hotel where they were coming from
and also um Trevor ree Jones who was her
bodyguard now he survived uh he's still
alive as of this and he was injured but
not horribly injured and that might have
been because he was the only one that
had a seat belt on which is uh yet
another thing that fuels a lot of
conspiracy
theories now interestingly okay so she
died in Paris um the official story
which most people know was that um the
car was being pursued by Paparazzi now
most of the photographers and [__] like
that were on like motorcycles vesas and
[__] like that and they were chasing
after the car like at high speed now hre
Paul was actually going to well
evidently he was actually going to Dodie
fed's house they had been at the Ritz
hotel in Paris which uh Dodie fed's
father
owned and Dodie fed's father later whose
name is Muhammad
he later told the media he's like I told
them because there was Paparazzi outside
of the hotel why don't they just stay in
the hotel like don't go back out because
they had been planning to go back out
and he's just like look everything you
need is there you don't need to go any
place blahy blah but they went they had
dinner there they went up in the room
for a little while and they're like no
we're going to go back out we got to get
away from all these people so they kind
of like snuck out of the hotel like they
did this whole thing where they had like
a decoy car in the front um that had
fed's regular driver driving that car so
that the paparazzi would follow them and
then the four of them went out the back
and like they rented a car Mercedes and
they went out the back and for a while
that worked but then the paparazzi like
caught onto it and then found the actual
Mercedes that they were actually in and
then started chasing them like I said so
like on motorcycles and stuff so the
official story being that because hre
Paul was driving apparently really fast
to try to get away from them there is
also um the official story is that his
blood alcohol level was three times over
the legal limit so he was pretty
hammered um and so and he was driving
like really really fast like through
this tunnel to get away from them and
just lost control of the car or another
car clipped them or he clipped you know
something in the tunnel and then he lost
control of the car he veered around this
other car and then slammed into uh like
a pillar like inside of the tunnel now
the car uh it's very easy to find
pictures of the car of the accident
scene um the car was [__] up I'm
actually surprised anybody survived only
one person did out of the four that were
in there but that car was annihilated I
mean it looked terrible now I will say
that one of the shitty things was that
the paparazzi reportedly um that were
following them they actually did not
help anybody that was in the car at
first they just started taking pictures
yeah of the wreck for you youngsters for
you youngsters that are too too too
young to
know back in the day we had Paparazzi
which are guys with cameras actual
[__] film cameras following
celebrities around take making a living
catching pictures of them yeah and
selling them to magazine hopefully doing
something scandalous or looking fat or
something right that totally obsolete by
the day standards because now you got
cell phones everybody has a [__]
camera right and you see a celebrity
just take picture of well that picture
just goes it doesn't matter who gives a
[__] nobody cares what celebrities are
doing anymore because we have the
internet they're on the internet you
you've actually don't give a [__] about
the
celebrities back in this day well it
sold paper is sold papers and every the
media of all kinds were being channeled
through very [__] small amount of
venues television
channels and [__] newspapers that you
bought at the grocery grocery store at
the checkout stand it was a wild time
man I can't believe I [__] lived
through that [__] Paparazzi
yeah what the f that' be tot I don't
even think that exists anymore I think
it still does because I mean they still
have tabloid newspapers that still need
photographs um you know because you know
even though it's not in print or that's
not their main uh source of income
anymore they still need photos of [__]
to like put on their websites for people
to click click on so I do kind of feel
like maybe that maybe last I heard yeah
Victor said yeah they're still around
last I heard two years ago what
Paparazzi did that they did have some
Paparazzi in um LA and that they spent
most of their time hunting down
ticktockers yeah famous Tik Tock
[Laughter]
chicks mind-blowingly hilarious it's
like hopefully we'll get a shot of them
like [__] yeah I in a gang bang or
something yeah not even that they were
in their backyard hot tub yeah just a
tick
tocker or some [__] some Tick Tock chick
well yeah I mean and that's the thing
like you have to think this is back in
1997 Diana um even though she was
divorced from Charles at this stage was
still very much a beloved public figure
and she pretty much couldn't go anywhere
or do anything without people following
her around and taking pictures of her
because they were like really fascinated
like I said it's almost this is so weird
because it's almost like they were kind
of like oo scandalous it's like look
she's divorced she's dating like a
normal person but it's like the fact
that they just made this big deal about
it is like so weird and the thing about
it like they made a big deal this is
another thing that kind of kills me they
made a big deal about when she confessed
that she'd had an affair when she was
married as well but it's like Charles
started it she only [__] around after
it came out that he was [__] Camila
blls and she was like well [__] it I'm
just like no one's paying attention to
me I'm going to go [__] somebody too
which like I said that's fair play so
but for some reason everybody got mad at
her it seemed like for a little while
and then but like after that I think
like after the Charles [__] came out
they're like oh yeah he kind of was a
piece of [__] to her so you know and
then finally they granted him a divorce
it took a while I remember like the
Prime Minister had to like weigh in on
that [__] which is [__] crazy but
yeah I remember when that happened cuz
it was like super scandalous but they
the Royal Family never did like her the
fact and I don't know if this is the
case what I've heard is that Charles had
wanted to marry Camila from the
beginning because apparently he loved
the [__] out of her for whatever reason
I don't know maybe she's an awesome
person I don't know her but um you know
he would they found like his love
letters to her where he said he wanted
to live in her knickers I'm just like
gross but okay I was like what a weird
thing to say but um but yeah so like the
love letters are kind of gross like he
doesn't really know how to um talk sexy
to somebody which is not surprising if
you look at him but so they they had all
of that kind of stuff but then like I
guess like the family didn't like her
for some re because she was kind of
aristocracy and [__] too so it's not
like she was some commoner or something
but they didn't like her for whatever
reason so I guess he thought he couldn't
marry or was like oh [__] it I'm going
to [__] her anyway but I'll just marry
this other one that I kind of like so it
was always just kind of like cuz Diana
even said that I think that was another
reason that people like Prin Diana too
because they were used to the royal
family being very like buttoned up and
like not saying anything Diana would
come out and just like she was totally
open and she was like totally honest you
know she was like oh well there were
three of us in this marriage you know me
him and Camila yeah and I think people
liked that I mean they felt sorry for
her because she'd been put like kind of
in a shitty
situation um you know she had and she
was very open about her struggles with
like eating disorders and depression and
the fact that she was also so really I
mean she even had even though she came
from aristocracy she had a normal job
she was like a kindergarten teacher yeah
and she just like lived in an apartment
with her buddies before she got married
and [__] like that so I think people
could relate to her a lot more cuz she
wasn't as yeah she was rich and
everything like that but she seemed more
relatable you know because she seemed
like she did regular [__] and she just
talked like a regular person you know
even though she was obviously very
privileged so I think people kind of
relate to that uh in a way that they
didn't relate to the others because the
other I mean to me and I don't know like
I didn't grow up in the UK I've been
there but i' didn't grow up there so I
kind of feel like the royal family
almost seem like aliens or like not
humans because they don't live they
don't have to live in the real world at
all like they don't have to have any
interaction with like normal people or
do normal people things um so and I
think people almost saw them as like a
breed apart so I think when she came
along it was very refreshing freshing
because she was still kind of in the
royal family but she still seemed like a
normal person so I think a lot of people
like related to that but it did seem
kind of interesting that people got all
up in her Grill about having an affair I
was like even though Charles had had an
affair well at least that one he might
have had more than that but he wasn't
super concerned about that was just his
girlfriend they're not talking about the
damn hired help well that yeah well
that's what I mean that's just the one
they know about there might be lots more
I don't know no dudes at this level play
call girls
constantly when I was growing up in
Brazil you know my friends who were
teenagers [__] were dealing with call
girls now they were teenagers too late
17 18 19 yeah age of consent in Brazil
especially back then I don't even think
it
existed CU we could get into nightclubs
at [__]
14 yeah you know you know just as long
as it wasn't a little kid right you know
I don't think if you were in that club
you were a fair
game [__] but all the dudes I grew up
in
Brazil yeah man and they were rich
kids if you have [__] if your dad if
you're if you're 17 and your Dad gives
the allowance of the equivalent of like
$500 a month all right then you can have
like $1 1225 you know $150 a week you
can spend that well that's a lot of
money in
Brazil all
right so I mean you know that's a place
where a drink is like a150 in a
nightclub maybe maybe $2
dolls so a kid who's going to school
just spending $125 a weekend you know
what I
mean [__] in a country where like I
think the average income is probably you
know [__] at that time time 10,000 US
dollar a year maybe a little bit more no
they were running call
girls yeah yeah well and half naked you
said uh he did he had two Mistresses in
fact yeah that doesn't surprise me at
all yeah and I mean that's that's
generous considering what the [__] he
looks like yeah and I'm sure he's really
not fun to hang hang out with either
yeah he doesn't seem like he'd be fun to
hang out with right Tyler says who would
have thought that if royalty actually
opened up to their subjects and tried to
understand them they'd be more liked
right it's just like it kills me that
the Royals like really disliked her and
kind of froze her out pretty much for
that very reason because people liked
maybe they were jealous they're like why
does everybody like her and not us I'm
like gee I
wonder just look at these if you were
just like a normal [__] person maybe
you'd know the answer to that
question I kind of I kind of respect uh
England holding on to their holding on
to their Traditions you know
and wanting to be like a constitutional
monarchy cross between kind of like a
monarchy and a republic kind of happen
at the same time I think that's a cool
idea but when it comes to the to these
uh to the Royal Family itself it needs
new
blood and you know you got to bring in
what they would call
commoners and to strengthen them you
know give them some more divers genetic
diversity and they'll get better looking
pretty quick you can reverse a lot it
can only help but the thing is is that
they trying to consolidate power yeah
and keep it all and that's the problem
with monarchies monarchy is a good idea
because a lot of times monarchs care
about the country and they care about
the people because if the country no no
no listen to what I'm saying listen to
what I'm
saying it's an evolutionary [__]
situation a lot of times monarchs when
they first get into power for the first
few Generations maybe [__] 60 70
maybe even 100 years they might actually
care about the country and the people
because they're related to them and if
the country gets [__] up then they
lose their Kingdom and then they get
ousted and
overthrown um you know so they kind of
have a supposedly have a personal tie to
the people and the
land but if it goes on for too long they
start there start to be some
corruption where it no longer works like
it should they they don't give a [__]
about the people they become kind of
more like care worried about other Royal
people that they're marrying in other
countries and they don't care about the
economy and they don't the power that
they used to have anyway well yeah and I
think that the modern world that's it's
a different situation nowadays and I
don't think it I don't think you can
extrapolate what might have been okay
like back then it just wouldn't work the
same nowadays because nowadays uh you
know the the royal family they don't
really have any incentive to give a [__]
about the Hoy pooy right well that's
because they don't really have much
power either the well that too which is
good I don't think I don't think theyy
monarchy got replaced by by corporations
basically and oligarchs that's not
that's not good either and they're
actually might be worse you know uh if
you look at history and I'm I'm not talk
I'm talking about human
history monarchy is the standard and it
it works in general it's pretty damn
stable uh Egypt was around for [__]
thousands of years China's kind of
monarchy uh up until recently thousands
of years of that yeah they fought each
other but Nations fight each other it's
just the way it is so I'm not an anti-
Royal I'm not I'm not anti monarchy
monarchies tend to be stable the problem
with monarchies is that there isn't any
constitutions and the monarchs can do
whatever they want but hey the British
solved that what was the name of that
[__] thing the Magna Carta said the
[__] King could do [__] but he limits
to your power you know and [__] you
got to worry about the people yeah butan
he's a little fence around so I don't
have any problem with you're not the
only [__] person on Earth you know I
don't have any problem with monarchy as
long as there's a it's a constitutional
monarchy that that that would be a lot
better and you but you have to have
monarchs that are that can protect the
people against corporations especially
if they're foreign corporations that's
even worse because that's that was the
main weapon of of the white man was to
send our corporations into foreign lands
and [__] them up they would [__] people
up not using armies using corporations
like the East India Company and
railroads and [__] like that so
corporations are the [__] best way to
[__] over
enemies armies are low
Tech all right so let's get back to the
topic back to the topic I'm just saying
I'm not I've only just started I I got
all that damn I got all that to go damn
she's got a [__] I got all that to go
you got the entire Old Testament there
no I don't it's not that much it's just
you need to rain it in also go give me
another drink please
yeah so okay so the official report like
I said now here's another thing that a
lot of people thought was suspicious the
accident happened in
1997 there was not like a formal inquest
in France until I believe 2004 and then
there was one in the UK after much uh
you know discussion and controversy in
2008 however every inquest that has been
done and I know that some people don't
believe the [__] and everything like
that but every inquest that has been
been done they have all come to the same
conclusion that the that it was one it
was a total accident and that it
happened because hre Paul was very drunk
uh was driving very fast because he was
being pursued by Paparazzi was trying to
get away from them and that it was just
a terrible accident that there was
nothing else going on also um the fact
that only one of the passengers Trevor
ree Jones had their seat belt on uh
was another contributing factor because
he was indeed the only person that
survived like he was injured I think his
face was kind of [__] up and stuff
like that but I saw an interview with
him that was like several years old and
he like he's got a few scars on his face
but he still looks normal like he
wouldn't you know think anything about
it um so the fact that the other three
didn't have uh seat bels on that's
another contributor to like a lot of the
conspiracy theories people say oh were
they [__] with or why didn't they have
them on because you know D family would
always say oh she always put them on and
[__] like that they think that they
didn't put them on because they were
trying to duck down in the back of the
car you know what I mean like I mean and
I will say look I always put my seat
belt on in the front seat if I'm in the
back seat I don't usually bother I
probably should but I don't and they
were in the back seat so maybe they
didn't bother and also like I said they
were kind of trying to duck down so they
didn't get pictures taken of them
because the photographers are following
them so I kind of think that's what it
was but that was what the official
report said both of the inquest but the
French one which was the first one that
was done and the British one came to the
same conclusion that this was just the
driver was drunk and he was going too
fast and he just lost control of the car
and maybe another car clipped them and
like he lost control and like went into
the pillar they said if he had hit some
other part of the tunnel it might have
been it might not have been as bad but
the fact that he hit the pillar cuz what
happened I saw like a animation like a
reenactment of it it seemed like the car
was like he was kind of fishtailing a
little bit cuz he was going so fast I
know how fast he was going they're not
entirely sure they made a lot of the
fact that when they you know found the
wreckage of the car um the
speedometer was um stuck at 121 miles an
hour miles or kilometers miles an hour
but that fast well see well here's the
thing so so they made and it was like a
big headline 121 miles an hour but the
Mercedes the the makers of Mercedes said
well that's not necessarily the case
they said usually if uh you know if the
car crashes or like it loses electrical
power or something like that they said a
lot of times the speedometer will either
go all the way to zero or it'll all the
go all the way to maximum so it's like
so yeah he could have been going 121
miles hour but probably more like 70
Maybe not maybe not um there was like a
quite a long uh yeah tire track tire
track like I think 50 skid mark skid
mark That's what I was trying to think
of um 53 ft 58t something like that um
but they couldn't tell how fast he was
going from that now he was speeding for
sure cuz the act the speed limit through
that tunnel I think was only 35 mil hour
and he was definitely going much faster
than that um but 1201 miles hour they're
not entirely sure there's no way of
knowing so I don't really know but he
was speeding for sure whether he was
drunk or not there's a lot of
controversy about that too which we'll
get into in a little bit um but yeah
so like I said so as soon as the
accident happened I kind of feel like
because
this was such a beloved public figure
known the world over people are going to
be like well can't she can't have just
died in like some stupid drunk driving
accident you know what I mean it had to
be something more to it so I do kind of
feel like a lot of um you know
conspiracy theor started early on but I
will say that a lot of them have been
spurred by Dodie fed's father uh
Muhammad Al uh Alpha head um he was kind
of the one and he has like [__] tons of
money like I said he owns like all these
hotels in Paris he owns um just all kind
of he owns like a like a soccer team in
the UK he owns like all kind of [__] so
he has all the money he thinks that both
of them were murdered and he has hired
his own private investigators and [__]
like that and has made all kind of
allegations there were also a couple of
uh tabloids in the UK that also agreed
with him and thought that they had also
been murdered so they kind of like hired
their investigators and stuff like that
now
here's one thing too and I think maybe
this was the main contributor to why
these conspiracy theories started so
Diana had a butler whose name was Paul
barell and he ended up publishing this
note that he said that Diana had written
in 1993 which was four years before she
died this note read in part I'm sitting
here at my desk today in October longing
for someone to hug me and encourage me
to keep strong and hold my head high
this particular phase in my life is the
most dangerous someone whose name was
redacted is planning an accident in my
car break failure and serious head
injury in order to make the path clear
for him to marry him being Charles now
most people have speculated that the
someone whose name was redacted was
probably Prince Phillip allegedly um but
we don't really know here's the thing
though now if she did write
this that's kind of well Okay the reason
she wrote this they think was because
this was you know uh 3 years before or
four years rather before she died she
had just had some trouble with her car
and she was a little suspicious about it
like she thought they like somebody was
trying to like do something to her car
also she had a body guard that was
killed in a car accident that she also
thought was suspicious like after he
started like talking about some [__]
that he wasn't supposed to be talking
about so she started getting suspicious
oh they're going to kill me too
evidently if she really did write this
which most people think that she did but
she was actually um paranoid
about being bumped off and she actually
went on TV and said that her former
bodyguard who was killed in the car
accident she basically said he was
bumped off quote unquote she said that
on
TV so that's the only thing that really
kind of makes me because the thing about
it was that like the royal family is
just like oh she's unstable and blahy
blah but everybody that knew her
everybody that worked with her all their
bodyguards and all that other kind of
stuff said she always seemed like a very
rational very
levelheaded uh person like she had a
great sense of humor she just seemed
like a regular person you know what I
mean she didn't seem like she was crazy
or paranoid or nothing like that so it's
like if she was thinking that
there might have been a reason she was
thinking that you know that's all
they're saying they're not saying that
it really happened or nothing like that
but that is one thing that kind of like
bothers me is that it did occur to her
uh that maybe they would try to like
make [__] look like an accident you know
what I mean that's a little bit gives
you a little bit of a pause also her
solicitor said that um he
thought that her that Diana and also
Camila would be quote unquote put aside
so that Charles could marry this other
chick named what is her name Tiggy leg
or leggy Burke which is like the most
twe upper class twit name that I've ever
heard um even though he did end up like
marrying Camila and the end so I don't
know and the thing about it was that I
kind but the thing about it I'm not
saying that she didn't have a reason
that she felt like that I'm just saying
that after she was granted the divorce
from Charles there was no reason why he
couldn't marry whoever he wanted to
marry and by the time that she died in
1997 they'd been divorced for a while so
you know a couple of years and so I just
kind of feel like why would they have to
kill her like he could already marry
whoever so I don't I don't really know
if there was any reason to do that after
that point yeah that's what I'm saying
because it's just kind of well there was
no reason they weren't married anymore
so he could marry and he did he married
Camila so I don't know if there was any
reason to kill her like at that stage
but I'm not saying that she didn't have
some reason for feeling like that in
1993 maybe there was like some weird
[__] going on and stuff like that
Charles did come out later and say that
he didn't he had no idea why she felt
like that like and everything like that
and all of the investigation said well
you know probably the royal family
didn't have anything to do with it they
probably didn't not saying they wouldn't
do some [__] like that because I'm sure
they probably would allegedly but um I
don't know if they did it I don't think
if they were going to do it they
probably would have done it then I kind
of feel like they would have done a long
time ago why would they have waited
until years later when she'd already did
because Dodie Fed was not the first
person that she dated after the divorce
she dated some other dude Like a Surgeon
like for two years you know and they
didn't seem to have a problem with that
like they didn't try to kill anybody so
I don't know I I feel like they wouldn't
have waited um somebody brought up the
pregnancy thing and I'll get into that
in a little
bit so okay so they did a whole thing
called uh in uh 2004 I guess they
started and they started doing operation
is it padet or page it looks like page
to me because padet I would think would
have a D in it at least in the English
language it's just p a g t and I heard
everybody in the documentaries pronounce
it padet so I guess that's how I'm going
to pronounce it even though it looks
like
pagey but so this uh you know kind of
task force or whatever they actually did
get together and they're like okay we're
going to investigate all these
conspiracy theories that been swirling
around because there were I'm not going
to cover all of these and I don't even
know what they all are but there were
like at least
175 conspiracy theories um that were
swirling around most of them from uh
Muhammad the you know Dodie fed's dad
Muhammad alfed he was the one that came
up with a lot of this and he seems like
a nice man I'm not I'm not saying that
but he did he does really believe that
they were murdered and uh he's just
trying to convince everybody of that I
can't really blame him but you know what
I mean so he came up with all kind of
crazy
[__] so first thing we'll get into so
hre Paul this was the guy that was
driving the
car so a lot of theories uh kind of
center around him that hre Paul might
have been perhaps um an agent of a
particular Secret Service um whether
American or French or British or
whatever uh or had something to do with
MI6 something like that now the things
that they use to uh back up this
assertion are that well he seemed to
have more money in his bank account than
his job would warrant uh which you know
doesn't really prove anything or I think
I've heard too that like oh there was a
big uh payment made in there but I don't
know if that's the case but they did
seem to think that he had a lot more
money in there than he should have had
so um so there was that now what the
thing is okay so he was like the head of
security I think he was either the head
of security or the second in command at
the rits in uh Paris where they left
from you know that's where they were
staying and I kind of feel like
maybe here's another thing that maybe a
lot of people that come up with this
don't know this like because they think
that it's like oh well they paid this
guy they set him up it's like you need
to like go drive and crash the car and
kill them
which one seems like kind of an
inefficient way to go about things
especially when the D when he got killed
too like hey we'll give you all this
money but guess what you're going to get
killed also um also um and like I said I
don't know if a lot of people know this
either but he wasn't actually he had
already um like clocked off work that
night he was actually because for a
while like uh Diana and doie fed weren't
going to leave the hotel they had gone
to the hotel there was Paparazzi all
around there and they were like like man
look at this [__] like cuz they were
going to go out again and they were like
maybe we shouldn't because they were
just everywhere and they didn't want to
deal with it because they were kind of
sick of it CU they' had been following
around like the whole time they were in
Paris right because I think they had
just been there I think they got there
like the day before or something so they
had Paparazzi following them everywhere
and they're like man this sucks and they
were like maybe we should just stay here
but then for whatever reason like after
a few hours they you know they had
dinner they kind of went and hung out in
the room they're like yeah maybe we
should go out and dod's like well let's
go to my house which was not that far it
was just like a few miles away so uh at
at that point hry Paul had actually kind
of gone off duty for the night so he was
gone for two or three hours so there's
like a two or three hour gap where
nobody really knows where he was he just
[__] off and did whatever he did and
then they called him back because they
said no we need you to come back here
and drive now he was not Dodie fed's
regular driver as I mentioned earlier
doie fiad had a regular driver at this
hotel cuz like I said this hotel his dad
owned it so so he stayed there all the
time um but they got his regular driver
to drive the decoy vehicle to get all of
the paparazi to follow that car because
they recognized his driver so they
thought that that would work so they got
hre Paul the second guy they're like you
come in here and drive and we'll sneak
out the back now the big thing about it
was that how
drunk was uh on repal at the time so
they did um a blood test on him
allegedly and it appeared that he was
over was about three times the French
legal limit or double the British legal
limit uh if you're you know um so there
was that they also found out later that
he was on anti-depressants a couple of
different anti-depressants which also
might have interfered with the alcohol
but that was from the blood test
conspiracy theorists though point out
that there is CCTV footage from inside
of the hotel which shows hre Paul
walking around um very shortly before he
got into you know got behind the wheel
of the car now I saw this CCTV footage
and I will say that he does appear to be
sober I mean he's not stumbling around
he's not I mean three times the legal
limit that's kind of a lot there is a
stage where he squats down and ties his
shoes like both of his shoes and then
he's like talking to people and stuff
and then he just walks over there he's
not stumbling He's not cuz if I was
three times the legue of limit I don't
think I'd be able to squat down and tie
my shoes that's for [__] sure but you
know it could be maybe he was just um
drank a lot and he was like used to it I
don't really know but so that's kind of
what a lot of the conspiracy theorists
say it's like well you see the CCTV
footage just like minutes before they
left and he doesn't look like he's
inebriated like at all which I will
agree he does not he's not stumbling
around he's not doing anything like that
I could be loaded but yeah so like I
said people hold their liquor
differently like I've seen you walk
around normal it's like just because I
would be that drunk and I wouldn't be
able to tie my shoes doesn't mean that
other people couldn't do it you know
what I'm saying I could be loaded to
drive
perfectly and other people could say
dude man you're driving good say yeah
now there have been times where I
couldn't yeah okay like back when we
came back from that strip club one time
was like driving looking through a t
toilet paper tube man I I can't believe
I made it back I can't believe it did
[__] that was uh that was quite a night
that was a long time ago yeah that was a
long time ago yeah um but yeah so I'm
just saying that they've done they did
the blood test and after the uh you know
those results were questioned they
actually did test on like the vitus eye
fluid which is supposed to be more you
know accurate and they're like yeah they
concluded that he was pretty drunk there
too even though like I said the CCTV
footage he doesn't look drunk on that um
at least some of the other people that
were working there that night said well
we didn't see him drink anything or he
didn't appear to be super inebriated but
like I said that doesn't necessarily
mean anything and the thing about it was
that um you know after he went off duty
I don't think he hung around I think he
went somewhere else so he maybe could
have gone some place else and drank or
you know they didn't see him drink I
think they only saw him drink like a
couple of drinks which you know but you
don't know how many he was drinking
before that so I don't know but that was
kind of another point of contention was
that they're like oh well he wasn't
drunk and they said he was because
another thing that happened and this C
came out in 2006 was that Lord Stevens
who was kind of like the head cop dude
person he had actually uh had a meeting
with hre Paul's parents who were quite
elderly at that
time and he allegedly specifically told
them oh we're not going to pin this on
your son it's like he wasn't drunk all
this other stuff but then like later on
they're like oh yeah he was totally
hammered and he was probably what caused
the accident he wasn't totally blamed
because they said well he was driving
fast and stuff like because the
paparazzi were after him because I don't
know if you know this but uh the French
police at the scene arrested seven of
the photographers for and they tried to
charge him with manslaughter but it
ended up like not getting got and I
think too they tried to charge them with
um like not rendering Aid because they
just kind of stood around and took
pictures of the wreckage without helping
anybody uh for a little while so the so
some of the um photographers and [__]
did get arrested seven of them did but
um they ended up getting off like
without any charges and [__] like that
but it was kind of a [__] up situation
all around so but yeah so they made much
of the fact that Lord Stevens had told
hre Paul's parents oh we're not going to
you know essentially we're not going to
throw your son under the bus we're not
saying that he was the one that caused
it and stuff like that but then when the
inquest results came out the results
were well he was really really drunk and
he was driving really fast and he lost
control of the car so they were kind of
pinning it on him so a lot of conspiracy
theories will point that out too it's
like well why did he tell the parents
that I don't know maybe he was just
trying to make them feel better you know
and then he's like well never mind or
maybe he didn't know maybe he didn't
know and like I said he was just trying
to make I don't really know how that uh
all happen yeah I'm going to have to
take some of that damn [__] nose
medicine what happened I don't know it's
all getting all stuffed
up I take one of those antihist means be
back in second okay you got a
pill yeah Allison said uh you can build
up a hell of a tolerance yeah and I had
thought and I mean this is again alleged
um that hre Paul I I'm not saying was an
alcoholic but a lot of people said that
he drank quite a bit um so the more that
you drink the more of a tolerance that
you build up so me seeing him walk
around on the C CCTV like just acting
like normal I was like yeah to me that
looks normal and if I had drunk as much
as they say that he drunk yeah I'd
probably be like flopping around and
running into walls and stuff but other
people are not me like you know so maybe
he was like really hammered and he just
didn't look like it I don't really know
um you know but that's that's the thing
like the other guy like Trevor ree Jones
um there's also CCTV footage and it's
kind of like [__] up to watch it
there's also CCTV footage AG in the Ritz
which was just like a couple hours maybe
not even a couple hours before the
accident happened where all four of them
are in a um an elevator like in the
hotel and Trevor ree Jones said that at
that point he didn't smell any alcohol
like on hre Paul's breath or anything
like that and he's just like well that's
just something you wouldn't have done
you wouldn't have got like super [__]
up like that like while you were on the
job but like I said he wasn't on on the
job he had kind of clocked off and then
was called back cuz they're like oh we
decided to go somewhere you know and we
need you to drive but I don't know I
don't know so I don't know how much he
drunk but like I said blood alcohol
vitous eye everything like that said he
was three times over the legal limit
which is a lot which is a lot and he was
driving super fast
apparently um now okay so there was this
other guy too and this is kind of
related there was this other guy named
Richard Tomlinson and he used to work
for
MI6 and uh I will say at first that he
was eventually uh fired from MI6 and um
also later served uh a few months in
prison for uh you know breaching the
official Secrets act so there's that so
we don't know how a trustworth he is but
he said um when they were doing the
French inquiry in
1999 that
MI6 had been involved in the
crash and that he had proof of this he
said and he would provide it to the
judge like at the
inquiry now he also had told the
BBC that HRI Paul the guy driving the
car was working for uh the security
services and that one of Dina's
bodyguards um either Trevor ree Jones
who was in the car or another guy named
Kess Wingfield um was a British
intelligence contact
now this guy also said oh that MI6 had
been like surveilling Diana before she
died now he said too and we'll get into
this in a little bit too he said that
they were going to kill her in the same
way like when he was in MI6 he said they
had this plan to assassinate um sladan
mosovich yeah um by like flashing lights
at the car and like causing the driver
to freak out like yeah so they had this
whole plan to do that and make it look
like an accident and so well no yeah
I'll get that but he just said he's like
yeah I saw the plans for that and it's
like they decided they were going to
kill Diana the same
way now a a few years after that in
2008 this guy's at the other inquest and
he says then he suddenly like walks it
back a little bit oh maybe you guys
misunderstood me or I didn't remember it
right um no I don't think hry Paul was
really an MI6 agent but um he did like
he was an informant for them like that's
what he said so I was like he's walking
it back a little bit because maybe he's
afraid he's going to get in trouble this
is like several years later um now after
this happened after these
allegations all of the um the people
involved in the inquiry the operation
pageant they let them go into MI5 and
MI6 and apparently gave them like just
like look whatever you want we don't
have have anything to hide so they let
him like look in there
apparently like that's what they said
anyway so they go and they look in there
and um they didn't really find anything
that that suggested that hory Paul like
worked for them uh in any capacity and
also they did find the the kind of memo
that he was talking about about the
whole uh movich thing he said what it
was was back in 1993 somebody somewhere
had just written it was wasn't like a
plan or anything it was just like a memo
like hey I got an idea or something it's
like um yeah we're going to assassinate
somebody and it wasn't even mosovich it
was some other guy like in Serbia I
don't know who it was but it's like
we're g to assassinate this other guy um
but it didn't have anything to do with
like flashing lights at the driver or
anything like that although that was
another thing we'll get into that later
because that's another conspiracy theory
about the whole flashing lights thing
but yeah so that's where he got the idea
from but they they found that that
wasn't really uh didn't really have
anything to back it up um also they
discovered that this guy Tomlinson had
been writing a book um and they found a
draft of his book that he had written in
1996 and he actually referred to this
memo that he was talking about where
they were assassinating this uh Serbian
person but he didn't mention anything
about oh and they also said they were
going to use this on Diana or use that
on something else which he did claim
later so they were like well why didn't
you say it back then then it's not in
your book so there we go um also they
had an anonymous uh informant who did
work for MI6 that said um that MI6 as
far as they were aware did not have any
files on Dodie F did not have any files
on the princess they were not watching
either one of them and they didn't have
anything to do with it and they didn't
know what they were talking about so
like I said that could be [__] but
that's what they that's what the
anonymous source said anyway that they
called Miss X actually now this
Tomlinson person was actually arrested
by the French in 2006 um just regarding
this whole sit situation and as I said
he did do 5 months in prison later on
for not for that but for you know other
[__] that he lied about [__] like that
so one of the reasons uh so let's talk
about dirty fiatt a little bit because
one of the reasons that a lot of people
think that Diana was murdered was
because of this relationship uh I this
is probably like the main reason and I
think one of the um things that people
point to the most is that probably she
was pregnant or she was going to marry
this
dude
now uh so here's the thing like a lot of
them have said and uh doi's father has
said this as well he's like they didn't
like the Roy family did not like the
idea of Diana dating a Muslim uh an
Egyptian Muslim and having a baby with
him that maybe would be like next in
line for the throne you know what I mean
[__] right so yeah well there's a
couple things like against that though
yeah like she wasn't married to that
dude anymore yeah one she wasn't married
to that dude anymore yeah two uh prior
to her going out with Dodie fed she had
dated another Muslim man uh a surgeon
for two years and reportedly the royal
family had absolutely no problem with it
um and Charles even gave it his Blessing
because they were actually talking about
getting married but then it didn't work
out the British royal family
is is heavily intertwined with the royal
families of Saudi Arabia they're almost
like business
partners been going on for a long time
they don't care about
that if you have money you're a
player yeah they don't really see they
don't care about ethnic groups or races
that's no they don't really care about
that I mean they did say like the man
that Diana was dating prior to Dodie fed
um he did say that he got a lot of hate
mail from members of the British public
because of course he did but nobody ever
said anything about the royal family
being shitty to him and they and like I
said they were um they they seemed to
like yeah if you want to marry him
that's okay you know what I mean rich
people don't care what your race are
they just care if you're rich they date
each othery and I can tell you this from
personal experience my [__] Uncle cw3
Frost he was in Task Force 160 Special
Operations Aviation when he [__]
retired and knew hung out with him up at
Fort Cavell when I was stationed there
when he retired he
became a private helicopter pilot and
bodyguard to a very rich dude in
Dubai and I hear it through family
connections of the [__] that goes down
there no they don't care
about oh he's Muslim they don't give a
[__] they only care about if you're
[__] rich and these dudes were and
these dudes are rich then there you go
yeah I mean doie Fed was Muslim but he
was like super rich he was a movie
producer and his dad was a billionaire
there's a big big difference between a
rich family
from Saudi Arabia or UAE or [__]
Egypt
or Dubai big difference between them and
say a poor family from [__] Morocco
big difference all right they don't even
look same they like two different
species uh but now they the rich people
all rub
elbows you know if you're rich and
Powerful
then you're in the club and those people
were all in the club so no they would
had a problem I'm not like I said I'm
not saying like you know the British
royal family isn't shitty in other ways
and I and I kind of feel like um Megan
marle got like a [__] ton of uh grief as
well but at least according at least in
this era at least according to everybody
that was involved and I'm not so much
talking about Dodie fed I was talking
about the dude she was dating prior to
that who like I said she dated for two
years um nobody really seemed to have a
problem with him other than some members
of the British public who sent him hate
mail yeah but um but the Roy didn't give
a [__] about that they didn't seem to uh
so I will give them that because like I
said he had money uh so I think he was
from Pakistan I think if I'm remembering
correctly I don't know but I'm just
saying that yeah they only care if you
have money and power
High Desert said that's the royal family
didn't like Megan Markle because she was
from a middle class nobody family yeah
maybe not so much because of the racial
thing maybe because she they thought she
was a commoner yeah ew yeah I'm G get
into some [__] later on they're talking
about MI6 and [__] yeah [__] Special
Operations don't forget we'll talk about
it later my mom state department and did
a bunch of wild [__] to Consulate in
Brazil That's how I got to
Brazil that [__] helped me in my
milit career later on and I was raised
in a military academy Southern
California Military Academy California
some of the listeners are guys I would
to school
with when people think of CIA and
[__] MI6 and everything they have
they're think of James Bond and doubl
that is not who those people
are no I know some CIA agents back from
those days and you would never suspect
him when you looked at them what you
think it' be dudes that look like me or
[__] David Daniel Craig or some [__]
like that no no I knew two of them one
was a fat
dude who [__] terrible physical
fitness the other one was an old lady
with [__] extremely crooked
teeth you would never expect suspect
that person is being a [__] spy well
that's exactly why they're a spy yeah
because no one would suspect no one
would suspect you you go around being
all swaave and everybody recognizing you
and stuff and calling attention to
yourself that's bad spying now recently
[__] that's been happening in
Afghanistan and
Iraq cia's performed some wet work down
there wet work means killing people but
they use an army dude as a contractor to
do it and it's usually a pretty easy
Mission you don't really need J James
Bond to do it closest dude to James Bond
ever I've ever [__] know of the clo
and I know the deal is a dude I was in
the army with named Timothy van van
vacus I can show you guys pictures of me
and him together our [__] yearbook up
the 506 he ended up running an
international band of mercenaries that
worked for Central and South American
governments as death squads and the CIA
was also involved he's in prison right
now he'll be out in a [__] couple
years he did he's doing time for a plot
to assassinate a [__] DEA
agent he's well known I can [__] you
can Google his name Tim
vacus I I grew up with him good guy and
when he was [__] doing that [__] in
my circles they would they were putting
out job applications good thing I didn't
get involved in that [__] but yeah and
then when he got popped we found out
more about him but I still love Tim
[__] we came up together and if yeah
okay he was targeted he and his group
targeted a DEA agent there was a reason
there had to
been and and his clients were always
Central and South American
governments and he also helped train
those [__] Mexican drug cartels he
and his group which that's another
because they're part of the governments
too of
Mexico how do you think those Senators
got elected how do you think it's a lot
dirtier than you think okay but anyway
this thing about
CIA or excuse me [__] MI6 trying to
kill princess die because she married it
just doesn't jive with my experience of
what they're interested in they wouldn't
give a [__] about that well and
Sebastian just made the point and this
is why I don't don't know why a lot of
conspiracy theorists are hung up on the
whole pregnancy angle is because if
Diana had a child with Dodie the child
wouldn't be in line to the throne
exactly right she already had two kids
with Charles and both of those kids as
far as I know were Charles's kids they
would be in line right right so it's
like if she they were divorced she went
off and married somebody else and had a
kid that would absolutely not [__]
matter to anything not give a [__] they
would be seed down the totem pole for
eligibility
because because it would go to who is
blood relative and right now and Charles
already had two sons it would be the two
two sons and then if [__] uh if those
two were
died or didn't make it it would be
somebody else in the family they would
[__] go for dukes and [__] like that
they wouldn't go for kids she had from a
marriage Pro after that she no no yeah
it wouldn't even be a consideration no
that's not how l so that's why I don't
really get why like I said it would be
more believable to me if she'd still
been married to him and like she was
having an affair with the dude and like
oh maybe she was pregnant even then I
still don't think they would have gone
that far but it would have been
more understandable like I don't know
why they would care like years later
she's dating some other dude and she
wasn't pregnant at least according to
the autopsy they're just like no she
wasn't but um and she uh you know she
would have said it like to her friends
and [__] like that they did blood tests
they did all that kind of stuff and it's
like there was they didn't find anything
so it's like but even if she was that
wouldn't have made them kill her because
it wouldn't have mattered she wasn't and
she was no longer like in consideration
like her children would have know I said
I think all CIA agents look like Tom
no no old they're they're just imagining
that old women with bad teeth and fat
dudes with the rald and no the their
whole thing is
camouflage and it's just information
they're not Fighters they're not Killers
or anything like that if they if they
ever need anything like that done they
use civilian contractors a lot of them
from mercenary types and and gangster
types that's what they would use that's
what they've been
using and then the if it's gangsters and
[__] they don't even know who they're
working
for they won't tell
them they just go to the Mob and put a
hit out for another guy and then the guy
that does the hit they don't even they
don't know who that was or who paid for
it so that's what you want to
use why would you use somebody that knew
what was going on yeah yeah totally
deniable Mr 88 said money May matter
more than race but race is not
inconsequential successful people from
India tend to be rapidly racist against
their children marrying non- Indians
yeah it it's definitely still a thing
well cast system down there yeah so it
might be more of a consideration there I
feel like right it's more of a big deal
I mean I'm not saying it's not a big
deal everywhere CU it is but I think in
India it's like way more of a big deal
my understanding that if you're
Brahman they want you to marry another
Brahman if it's not a Brahman it's okay
the the if it's not a
Brahman a a non Brahman the best of the
non- bramin would be some kind of an
Ango they'll because they evidently have
some of that in them
already but that that was just that's
just what I was told I don't know if
that's
true anglo-american or somebody from
England or in Australia that's okay or
not as bad as anybody else because there
there was inner breeding going on with
the English and the brahin evidently for
you know
because India was part of the British
Empire Michael says it was the paparazzi
and had an accident yeah and I'm I'm
willing to concede that hre Paul was
probably pretty drunk too and he was
speeding trying to get away from the
paparazzi so I think they were probably
both coupable but like I said it was
just a stupid accident it could happen
to anybody body just because she was a
princess that doesn't mean they don't
get in car accidents everybody does and
in fact that's probably the most
dangerous thing it's why I don't like to
you know I I'm scared of being an
accident because I feel like that's
probably the most likely thing that
would happen to me um Zack asked me what
the old lady do as a spy
spies watch listen and Report that's all
they do read newspapers and Report yeah
you don't need to be like running around
like Daniel Craig or nothing like
running around on buildings and blowing
[__] up and everything like that it's
mostly just gathering information and
anybody can do that right and also they
befriend key foreigners and bribe them
all right that's another thing bribery
so she meets a guy he works for another
government or some kind of company
befriends him and then comes out and
says look I work for some people that
are offering you can offer you a certain
amount of money and protection if
anything goes wrong if this and this we
just want this and this from you and
I'll give you
$20,000 right now that's what they're
doing that's how it actually that's how
they actually work yeah it's not as it's
not as sexy as it is in the movies
bribery that's that's mostly what it's
about like I said all it is is gathering
information you're supposed to get like
actionable intelligence is what your job
is another thing that the CIA does is by
whatever means necessary they infiltrate
other government offices like the state
department yeah or the Army and they're
in there as an as just an employee but
they're listen listening to what
everybody is saying all right and if
anything if anybody says anything out of
line they report that so they're kind of
like rats too yeah to make sure
that there aren't any moles in the in
the agent or PE in in the agency in
other words there aren't any moles in a
department or people that are working
against the interests of I guess the CIA
I don't trust them I wouldn't trust
them I think the CIA is a Thom that they
control themselves and that they're out
for their own thing because they have
the ability to
[__] basically steal cart blanch to
make money black
funding including drug dealing and human
trafficking they can make money from
that and keep it and buy houses with it
I would I don't trust them at all I
don't think there should be a
CIA neither did JFK and he ended up
getting shot in the head
okay Allison said uh they wear wigs to
disguise them like Jenny yeah that's
right I'm a secret service agent [__]
that's why I wear all these wigs really
it's just because my hair look [__] up
Michael says the only true conspiracy
out there is Katy Perry is jumping a
Ramsey grownup I've never heard that one
uh we'll have to like look into that as
a show yeah Victor says if William and
Harry died the next in line would have
been prince Andrew yeah now it's Charles
then William then William's son George
then his daughter yeah so I don't really
get this whole thing I don't don't get
why it would matter like why if she'd
had a baby with with somebody but she
wasn't pregnant though I mean at least
according to everything I ever read
Michael said do you guys ever wear
regular clothes like some J crew [__] or
something this is our regular clothes no
[__] we do not [__] no well yeah like I
said that's that's a good answer these
are a regular cloth [__] you talking I
don't have any regular clothes so it's
like so I get in a I get in a bit of a
pinch it's not usual that I have to like
wear any normal clothes for any reason
whatsoever but if I do I'm kind of in
trouble cuz I don't really have anything
closest thing I have to what you would
maybe think would be regular clothes is
[__] that looks like paramilitary
uniforms I wear a lot of [__]
tactical
pants do I have [__] just but that's
not weird to me that's my version of
work clothes yeah so you
know yeah but I don't wouldn't wear that
anywhere I wear that around the house
mowing lawns and [__] because I kind of
wonder sometimes if like um some people
think that goth people that's like a
costume or something it's not a costume
it's not it's just like their clothes
they just wear that all the time even
like the even pajamas and like [__] like
that it always has like that kind of
flare to it cuz that's what you pick out
like I have I have workout clothes and
stuff like that but it's all black and
it's all like has like skulls on it and
[__] like that yeah we don't own any of
the clothes you're talking about
anything like I really don't this has
been going on for decades I really don't
it's been going on since we were I don't
I don't have any like peach colored
polar or I don't have anything like that
nothing no absolutely nothing so if
somebody like came up with somebody hey
put on some normal clothes I would not
be able to I don't have anything and
what the thing is is this is normal
clothes yeah for us this is like normal
clothes you don't think about it that's
just what my clothes look like I'm just
in my sex outfit right now yeah but it's
the same thing as man it's the [__]
same oh he's doing it again I'm going to
do it again J doesn't like me [__] gr
it's the same thing as a [__] what a
pro wrestler would wear it's like a
wrestler it's like a wrestler's
outfit it's not revealing or anything
Victor says says y'all should do next
week shows in Dallas Cowboys jersey we'd
have to buy them though and I'm not
paying money for [__] yeah I don't have
any I'm not into the sports ball
situation I would not I would not waste
I can't stand sports ball no I can't
even so yeah I don't even like that
whole I don't like that whole culture I
don't
like fake masculinity I'm gonna [__]
tell youall something uh oh what sports
ball actually
is is this white males [__] idolizing
and kind of L than after black
males I kind of feel like there is an
aspect of it's gay as [__] I most people
would deny it but oh yeah that's exactly
what that is I'm seeing that [__] and
I'm going like why AR these white dudes
watching these black dudes [__] run
around and do all this [__] [__]
these black dudes are grab and then
they're grabbing each other's asses
they're [__] smacking each other
they're playing with balls it just comes
and then then they're like talking about
how fast that guy is and how and I'm
just looking at these [__] dudes
these fat out of shape [__] white
dudes and I'm going like you want to you
want to blow that dude don't you see but
they're not allowed to say that they
have to express it in other ways there's
an attraction but that's what they
mean it's okay you can say it look man
me and Jan are [__] in the sex
industry okay it's okay most of our
clients are by I [__] know I can see
it in dudes when they're like [__]
watching too closely on these
[__] if you are a black ball
player those [__] white dudes up
there with their wives are lusting over
you probably they just don't realize it
they're they're in denial of it I kind
of feel like bisexual well like I said
it's it's okay it's okay it's just go
ahead and admit what it is that's what I
mean NFL did come out and say it was gay
it's it does all the [__] and even at
the Oasis that biker Club they got dudes
from the north northern Yankee and
[__] dudes watching the damn ball
game and they're gay as [__] watching
that [__] yeah you look at them and I'm
just looking at these right and compared
to me these are women all right these
dudes they're like old women and they're
just [__] watching these [__]
strong fast powerful black dudes and
they're just [__] totally into this
[__] and I'm going like if those dudes
appeared here now you'd be the center of
a [__] gang bang an IR gay gang bang
and those dudes they would relent I
could just tell they'd be like oh yeah
this is [__] great and they' be
talking about the dude's score why he's
F they something new about themselves
yeah that's nice right sports are gay as
[__] just ask any gay dude like I said I
don't have any problem with like look
whatever weird fetish or anything as
long as you're not hurting anybody like
just admit it it's okay it's okay yeah
it's
okay that's why that's why I wouldn't
want to go back in
time uh to when I was younger because a
lot of times like it wasn't okay like
you couldn't tell people that but now
you can't and no one really giv [__]
yeah I came from the Real Sports US Army
infantry [__]
that would be gay Paradise actually but
we weren't even aware of it just [__]
a bunch of bonding and [__] [__] we're
we're all going to die together [__] it
you know they're going to kill us and
some of the best friendships I've ever
[__] had and no it's it wasn't sexual
but it's like living on a monastery or a
bunch of [__] Warrior [__] yeah
Warrior priests you know but no [__]
to this day J will tell you [__] we
like my [__] AG
I was a 60 Gunner he was My AG [__]
Sparks he he's married everything got
kids married a [__] beautiful black
woman and he's still like my [__]
brother yeah I know when his house
burned down and his dogs died they you
know we got social media they so I talk
I talked to CH Miguel chaffino my he's
like my other brother from California he
was a Cho and [__] we call each other
up and we would annihilate [__]
over over over each other cuz we love
each other yeah you know like at that we
grew up together basically that's
awesome yeah yeah it's okay yeah so I
don't understand why people like a mafia
I don't understand why people get so
weird what it is I think CI some of
these civilian dudes who are sports fans
are actually kind of displacing this
desire they wish they had that [__] yeah
maybe that's what it is they wish they
had those relationships with dudes yeah
like a a [__] like a tight
Brotherhood yeah so their their closest
thing is to admire through the sports
dudes should have really close
friendships well just like women should
have close friendship well everybody
should have close friendships period
exactly but you know what I mean exactly
we're just helping
y'all yeah it it is not exactly as it
appears and there there's deeper
rooted yeah primitive instincts
happening and things I agree yeah okay
I'm go the restroom okay thank you yeah
so I can actually yeah go ahead yeah PO
says but Ranger panties totally hetero
oh yeah hell yeah hell yeah hell yeah oh
Tom I oh I ain't scared he's not scared
I Ain scared sh man [__] we stream
together our job is to help dud jack off
right I mean I'm [__] the thing I
like about Tom is that he's like
aggressively hetero but also he's just
kind of like ah whatevers yeah I don't
give a [__] he doesn't give a [__] they
he's not threatened by he doesn't do
that weird like you know you know how
some straight dudes would be like o no
homo it's like Tom doesn't give a [__]
about I don't give a [__] he doesn't
give a [__] about any of that so I was
like so I like that I like that he's not
afraid of like looking like oh my God
I'm going to look like I'm gay or
something like he doesn't care about
that and I was like that's good that's
because you shouldn't care you shouldn't
care it's nobody else's business and you
shouldn't care I don't understand why
people care uh like I said it's a lot
better now in that regard than it used
to be because we grew up in the 80s and
that [__] sucked kind of you couldn't
you had to be like a specific thing you
had to look a specific way you had to be
a specific way otherwise people would
say [__] about you you know what I mean
they still do that now I'm not saying
that but it's different it's
different picture says I'm in a dudes
and I say no homo for so I hope you do
because that's [__] hilarious that's
hilarious but uh yeah you know uh PO
says you cannot say Tom lacks a sense of
humor again that's what I'm saying
honestly I think that is probably my
favorite thing about him is that he
every single day he makes me [__]
laugh about something he's hilarious you
know what I mean he's crazy but he's
also hilarious like this the [__] he
comes up with is just like so [__]
funny because he doesn't care and he
doesn't have a filter at all he'll just
like shoot off whatever crosses his
brain he'll just it'll come out of his
mouth and it's just like super funny
like sometimes it's [__] up but it's
usually like pretty funny you
know so uh so yeah so again I kind of
feel like okay so the whole reason why
they had this whole thing
about her being pregnant which she
wasn't at least according to the autopsy
they're like look we checked we checked
her the you know they checked the body I
know this is indelicate but they checked
the body they also did because people
were not believing that they even
checked the blood this is [__] up but
they even checked the blood that was in
the car like her blood that was in the
car you know what I mean they checked
that too like for pregnancy hormones we
didn't see anything they also
interviewed all our friends friends and
all our friends said yeah no she wasn't
pregnant she would have told us it's
like she was still on birth control she
was still having her period you know
like everybody said and like you know so
you know they knew and so there wasn't
any of that so kind of related to that
was another thing where well even if she
wasn't pregnant she was going to marry
this dude and one of the things that
they point out is that that night like
before they died like that day before
she died
that um Dodie fied had gone to um the
Jewelers like around there uh what is it
called rosi raposi I guess I'm
pronouncing that right he went to the
jewelry store and bought he didn't take
it home but
apparently allegedly he like picked out
a ring or two
rings now
again um one they hadn't been dating
that long I think 7 weeks was as long as
they had known each other which seems a
little soon to be asking somebody to
marry you you know what I mean uh so
there's
that um and Diana had expressed to
several of her friends that she was not
I mean she hadn't said anything about
wanting to marry him particularly or um
I think one of the quotes that she gave
to one of her friends was I need
marriage like I need a rash on my face
so she wasn't real uh down with the
situation
uh and I think she had even said oh if
he asked me to marry him you know I'm
not going to do that [__] because I
don't need that [__] again which you
know is understandable so you know I I
don't know how that was all going I
don't even know if those were supposed
to be engagement rings now he did not go
to the jewelry store and buy them that
night though he did go in there they
have footage of him on the
CCTV and he might have picked some [__]
out but it looked like one of the
employees at the Ritz at the hotel
had kind of selected one and then like
kind of picked it out and like put it
aside but nobody took it home actually
like jie fi's Dad bought it later like
the one he had picked it out because I
think that they picked it out and it's
like oh they're going to have it resized
like they do with rings and then they'll
come back and pick it up later but
obviously they died that night so they
didn't do it so a lot of people were
kind of like oh well he was going to ask
her to marry him and then they were
going to announce the engagement on the
Monday like but you know they got
killed but as I said I
don't maybe but I don't know Diana
didn't seem to know anything about it
she had spoken to some of her friends
over the you know in the days before she
died and she didn't say anything about
oh some big announcement coming or
nothing like that so if he was planning
to do that one it seemed a little
premature because they had known each
other that long and two she didn't
really seem to have any inkling of it
she didn't really seem to want to get
married again at least at that juncture
so I'm not really sure how that would
happen and again I'm not really sure why
her getting married just like her
getting pregnant would have um
necessitated the royal family having her
killed that seems a little out there and
like I said it's there just doesn't
really seem to be any reason for it
because like I said she was no longer in
line for the throne that was nothing
she'd already had kids with Charles yeah
you know it it was a done deal VP pose
and there saying the assassination
Theory make any sense it really doesn't
it it doesn't seem like there's and and
I'm not saying that like you know the
rich people don't have people bumped off
they do but I'm just saying that in this
situation it really didn't seem like if
they had wanted to do that to her they
would have done it a lot earlier I feel
like when she was and they would have
done it in the way you and they would
have done it like kind of in a way that
you never suspected it it would have
look like suicide yeah see I'm not
saying that they didn't have I mean
there was a lot of uh resentment there
was a lot of um you know contention
between them uh the royal family never
liked her she like I said she spoke very
openly about uh the problems that she
had with Charles she wasn't like the
other Royals uh and they didn't like
that because they kind of like to keep
everything close to the vest you know
what I mean and they didn't like her
just out there like being all normal and
genuine and stuff and so there was a lot
of um and there was a lot made too of
like the [__] Queen after Diana died
and I remember this happened I remember
there was like a huge [__] outcry
about it cuz like I said I was in my 20s
like when this happened this was
1997 um the queen did not make a
statement about her death until five
days after the accident which is not a
good look going to say um everybody knew
that they didn't get along but that's
still kind of [__] up the queen still
alive isn't she no she's dead she died
she died a couple years ago then yeah
Charles is king now yeah cuz she because
she lived a long long time she was in
her 90s she's coming up to 100 was well
that's what happens when you have all
the money
yeah they'll just take care of your ass
yeah you know what I mean um but yeah so
I did think that was kind of [__] up
and a lot of people were like H looking
a SCS um but I don't think it was any
big secret in the UK that like Diana and
the royal family did not it along you
know but it was still pretty [__] up
it did it wasn't good optics for the
queen to wait that long after she got
killed in such a horrible way and she
was so young I mean she was only 36 and
it was [__] up that that the queen
waited so long to come out and go well
we feel very badly about you know well
there may have been there may have been
logistical stuff happened maybe but
still it still seems like kind of [__]
up yeah said damn damn Victor said she
died last September 8th yeah I knew it
was like fairly recently yeah so like a
year ago right she was old as [__] yeah
she's like one of the old SK Skies she
did kind of look like that actually I'm
talking [__] about her when she was
young she was cute she was actually
pretty yeah she was actually like pretty
hot when she was C she was cute even end
of the
70s
yeah so she's a cute Queen post says
stem cell smoothies yeah that might be
what it is why they live so
long but yeah so like I said even if jie
fet had been planning to propose
marriage which maybe he was maybe he
wasn't he did buy some rings uh that
night but I don't know if they were just
regular ass Rings or engagement rings or
I don't really know um but at any rate
she didn't seem to know about it one
two um she probably would have said no
cuz they hadn't really been going out
that long and she had told some of her
other friends even if he did give me
ring I'd put it on my other hand you
know what I mean like so she wasn't like
she did say something like that to one
of her friends so she wasn't like real
in a real hurry like to get married
again CU you know the first one went
kind of shitty so for her so you know
but even but like I said even if that
was the case it wouldn't really matter
because why would it matter like why
would they kill her over something like
that so there's that whole thing um so
let's get into we talked about pregnancy
already
another thing that people bring up uh in
regards to the whole thing being a
conspiracy was that there weren't any
CCTV images of the actual crash and some
people have found that very suspicious
as though somebody knew like that they
were going to turn the cameras off or
like they wouldn't have any record of
what actually happened or anything like
that which like I said does sound kind
of fishy on the surface but maybe I
don't know if you look a little bit more
into it it doesn't seem all that fishy
so the thing about it so there were some
CCTV cameras this is in Paris they do
have CCTV cameras
all um however the ones that were inside
the tunnel they had a bunch outside the
tunnel but they were usually like facing
they were kind of at the entrance and
those ones were not maintained by the
city because they were private like all
the private businesses along there they
owned those and most of those cameras
were facing towards the entrances of the
businesses because obviously they wanted
to see if any was breaking in right
that's why they paid for those now they
said they did have cameras inside the
tunnel but they didn't run them all
night it was usually kind of I think it
was like 11:00 p.m. they would turn them
off and they don't really have anybody
monitoring them after that time so you
know even though some people thought it
was kind of suspicious oh somebody
turned all the cameras off but they're
like no they were normally off uh cuz
this kind of happened like after
midnight like between midnight and 1:00
a.m. so it's was just kind of like the
middle the night and they're like yeah
we just didn't have anybody monitoring
them after that time and we didn't
record because I guess they didn't
really see any need to and so they never
had so all the cameras in there were not
working at that point so like I said
yeah you can kind of feel that
suspicious but as far as I know uh they
never had those cameras going at that
time of night so nobody thought that
anything about that so now here's a
whole thing about this alleged other car
there's a little car uh we don't have
these in the US but there's a white Fiat
Uno it's kind of a little it kind of
when I looked at the picture it kind of
look like a pinto but sort of to
me so they do know I'm pretty sure that
they know that there was a white Fiat
Uno involved in the crash somehow that
left the scene because one of the um
side mirrors of the Mercedes
had come off and it had chips of paint
on it that were from a white Fiat Uno
like they knew that that was like the
paint style that had been used on that
particular
car so they did know that there was one
involved and that it had left the scene
at some point so they're like well we
need to find this person because maybe
they had somebody to do with something
so they did kind of look into that now
it turned out and this was again an
allegation made by Muhammad Al fed Dodie
fed's
father he said that um the white Fiat
was
actually uh whoever was driving it
worked for MI6 again um and was
deliberately driving through the tunnel
and like you know kind of sideswiped the
Mercedes like to make it crash you know
what I mean that was his allegation like
I said this car did exist they did find
the paint on the wreckage but whether it
was deliberate or not I don't know now
the um um allegation at the time was
that this car was owned by a French
photojournalist whose name was Jean Paul
James at
enel now according to Muhammad alfed
this was a dude who worked for some
Secret Service or other and he had
actually taken pictures of Diana while
she was in uh San Trope in 1997 like
like a month prior to her death um he
was a photojournalist he did take
pictures of celebrities and [__] like
that so that's not a crazy thing to say
now we'll get into this in a bit but he
died in kind of a suspicious way I don't
know if it's suspicious suspicious but
it's a little bit suspicious he did die
in the suspicious way in 2000 so we'll
get into that and that was another thing
that Muhammad Alfa had used because he's
like oh well somebody murdered him
because he was like about to talk or
some [__] like that now the when they so
the um operation pageant did look into
this whole white Uno situation cuz like
I said that car did hit them but they
don't know how much it did you know if
it contributed to the crash or not they
just did found a little bit of paint on
the
mirror now when they found the car that
was owned by uh anden some they said
that when they found it it wasn't really
driveable like in the sense that it was
kind of in bad shape uh it was several
years old it had 202,000 miles on it and
um he hadn't really been taking care of
it it was just kind of like parked out
in the [__] field or some [__] like
that um and the dude's neighbor said
yeah he has it's just kind of been
sitting there he hasn't really been
doing anything with it now he actually
did sell the car uh a few months after
the accident that killed Diana in
October of
1997 now because of the condition that
the car was in
and um the fact that uh the dude had not
really tried to cover up the fact that
he had sold it so the investigators
thought well it's probably not this
probably wasn't the car that was in the
tunnel at the time um you know as far as
I know they didn't really look that much
further into it than that they were
looking for that driver because like I
said that car was
there so the French police did spend uh
quite a while after that like looking
for another car that might have been
involved um but you know didn't really
come up with too much stuff although we
talk about another guy later on now this
the dude that drove this uh allegedly
drove this car named um andanson the
French police had interviewed him in uh
February of 1998 not too long after the
accident like several months after the
accident and he was able to give them uh
evidence of where he had been at the
time so it did appear that he could not
have been in Paris at the time of the
accident uh that he was at his house
which was you know almost 200 miles away
and it looked as though that held
up now he
died in May of
2000 how he died was they found him in
his car not that one it was a
BMW he had
apparently sat in his car and set
himself on fire damn which man if you're
if you're going to kill yourself that is
a [__] of a way to go there's much
terrible there's much less painful ways
if that's what you're going to do and
I'm just kind of like that is pretty
[__] up so because that is [__] up
and that's not usually a way that people
would do away with themselves so a lot
of people have said well he must have
been murdered because he knew something
about that they did find him and this is
real [__] up when they found him like
he was just like in this field or
whatever and the car is burning and they
find him in there and his head had come
off like his head was in the middle of
the like you know where the what do you
call that thing the thing in the Middle
where the cup holders and [__] are uh
[__] what do you call that thing console
console the center console console was
the word I was looking for so yeah they
found like his head in there like his
head had come off um and they did find
kind of like a hole in his head but they
so some people were like oo Bullet Hole
but they're like well no they thought
that it was maybe just from the fire but
the fact
that like I said it seems like kind of a
[__] up way to go I'm not saying
there's like a conspiracy theory or
anything like that it does appear by all
you know uh reports that he did kill
himself but that really does seem like a
[__] up wait it to set yourself on
fire cuz I'm not thinking I think he
shot himself first they didn't find any
they didn't find like a firearm or
anything so he just sat in his car and
[__] bur worst way to go that's what
I mean it's like I can't really skin
falls off you inhale the Flames during
all the screaming it's a it's a slow
death yeah I can't imagine like why
would you want to like off yourself that
way that's awful set yourself on fire is
one of the worst but I think that's why
so many people cuz like cuz he died in
such a horrible way and even though
everyone said oh it's suicide but
everyone's like why would anybody do
that to themselves jumping out of a
window is a lot better yeah I wouldn't
even do that you got to go through the
fall yeah the best is just drugs or
drink yourself to
death that's what I mean it just seems
like a lot you can take the end of a
douchebag the [__] hose with the
[__] inserter put that in the [__]
end of a damn fifth of [__] VOD vodka
hang it up put that up in your
booty it'll hit you so hard you'll pass
out if that shit's in there it'll
probably be fair Pleasant it'll kill you
yeah you'll pass and it'll kill you
dudes have done it before yeah by the
way we just got a message from Bri
asking if we were going to go Friday and
I said yes yes we're going forid he
loves us you know she gonna ask him
about what's that are we going oh I'm
not gonna say yeah we're gonna go we're
g well no I'm not I was goingon to say
something else but then I'm like oh yeah
I can't say anything yeah I can't say
anything yeah she was she was hinting
around about you know n I'll tell you
later I told Jen I told Jen I was gonna
get her a girlfriend and I found her
nerdy and cute and everything in the
goth stuff she's a Gothic clown she
would Dr a clown she could be watching
she's only 22 though yeah she could be
my daughter she's a little young it's a
little weird yeah but I like her though
she's nice yeah she's good but uh yeah
Brie's trying to get it in on too well
did you know that yeah I figured yeah
yeah Bri Bri wants to come I mean last
time we hadn't seen her in a while and
then we saw her yeah a c few weeks ago
and I got that impression she was
talking about well my boyfriend cheated
on me with this chick so I went and got
in Revenge on him by [__] her you
know and [__] he found out fair oh
and then he got mad yeah he got mad why
did he get mad I don't know why he got
mad I [__] turn play bit yeah yeah
that's how that goes that's the same
[__] I would do right you did that [__]
to me I'd get Bri has a long history of
Bri has a long history I would do [__]
despite you of being in thres
yeah she's she's good looking good
looking tall funny she's gorgeous
actually yeah she's got a kid though
he's but he know he's grown yeah the kid
it's not like a little kid's grown he's
older he's 12 I think
yeah Victor says your head coming off is
not good trust me I'm a nurse
right then Tammy said thanks wasn't sure
myself yeah it's like you might want to
get that looked at your head falling off
and everything but yeah um apparently
what he did was he went he sat in the
car
like covered the car with gasoline and
then like lit a cigar and like let it I
was just like maybe some people are just
like [__] masochist man but I don't
know that's how he did it I've only
heard of one person another person
personally in my sphere that set
themselves on fire that's [__] up and
um when I was living in
Boston in that apartment at Winter Hill
this is after the time I saw [__]
what's his name [__] Lefty buer is
that his name Whitey Whitey buer yeah I
saw the guy I saw Whitey buer and his
[__] crew uh unloading some stuff out
of a [__] out of a [__] candy shop
that's now gone because I looked for
it I befriended a couple that lived
across from me in in my apartment and
she was a basically like a some kind of
a Health and Welfare type person she
took care of mental
outpatients I can't remember her name
off the top of my head I it would take
me a while to remember it
um she was she was a nice lady probably
about 10 years older than me at the
time she was taking care of an
outpatient that had been sexually abused
by her father and other people and
uh something happened to her she
couldn't take it anymore she got on top
of her [__] bed with a 5 gallon can
of gasoline and poured it all over the
bed and set herself on fire and
unfortunately burned down about most of
the floor she was on too she burned up
extra people's [__] right that's you
know didn't kill anybody else but burned
up all there [__] that's why I would
never do that it just seems like um yeah
too much there's just too much um
possibility that something would go
wrong and somebody else would get hurt
and I would never do that so so I asked
her I said what why the [__] that method
and she said usually what happens is
with them is that they want the
suffering because they feel they deserve
they're trying to purge
themselves and I said what do you mean
what do you talking about she goes well
she was doing this with her dad but it
went on for a long time and she was she
felt that she was involved in it that
this was and then afterward guilty about
a lot with um with girls that uh that
have that kind of abuse that go on for a
long time well it's almost but you kind
of get the fact that you're like
complicit yeah right so you feel like
really guilty about it like it's like
well I allowed it to happen so I must
have wanted it to happen like I get it
yeah because well like I said in general
this is just a generalization but uh in
general women do tend to blame
themselves yeah for whatever happens
whether it's possible that it's their
fault or not yeah so um that's why we're
so messed up yeah you know what I mean
the only person I've ever heard of this
between friends that set themselves on
fire I mean it does happen like it does
happen people he said setting yourself
on fire is a [__] bad sign of guilt
yeah based on what which I get I get it
um and I think like I said that's what
kind of fueled the EXP the uh conspiracy
theories about this guy because they're
like well one if he did do himself in by
doing that it's like oh he must have
been really guilty because he was
involved but he didn't want to tell
anybody or alternately um he didn't do
himself in and got whacked because he
knew some [__] that he
shouldn't know but like I said I'm not
it's not impossible that he did decide
to do himself in because people do do it
and like I said I think it's usually
like Tom said I think it's usually
people that want to that feel like they
should um suffer that they need to
suffer for something
whether uh you know justifiably or not
probably not justifiably but I do kind
of feel like a lot of them do feel like
that I will note um and this is just
here nor there I don't I don't
know uh if I believe what happened with
this dude but I will note that they
never did find the car
keys so it's a little bit sus but I'm
not just saying that I'm saying as far
as I know they never found the car keys
like the car was just out there and he
was on fire and uh you know and he died
so that's kind of [__] up but like I
said the report said oh he didn't have
anything to do with anything and
honestly they didn't even think that he
was was driving the car that was there
because he wasn't in Paris at the time I
mean they pretty well established that
he wasn't there so whatever it was that
he did himself in over if indeed he did
um then it probably wasn't anything to
do with that so like later on they found
out that maybe the driver of this uh
mysterious Fiat Uno that they never
could find was maybe this 22-year-old
Taxi Driver uh named Lan thanan I think
is how you pronounce his name now
several witnesses uh saw someone
matching his
description coming out of the tunnel uh
not too long after the crash so it's
possible that it could be him he did
have a car uh which was identical to the
one that uh looked like it sideswiped
the
Mercedes um so they did like narrow this
down and uh they found the paint and
everything like that so they thought
well could have been involved they did
find him and they did question him in
November of 1997 like not a few months
after the accident um but they asked to
review like they asked to interview him
further and he always refused he said
that he was at work at the time of the
crash he was actually a security guard
on the night shift at a factory um and
he said uh yeah it was me and this other
dude working but s suspiciously he could
never remember what the other dude's
name was like his
coworker um they and they never did like
check out The Alibi I think now it was
later discovered that it was entirely
possible that he could have left work
early that night and it so happened that
his dad lived right near that tunnel so
it's possible that he could have left
work early and gone to visit his dad and
been in the tunnel and sideswipe the car
and possibly maybe indirectly um helped
to cause the accident but there's really
no way of knowing that for sure um but
you know so they don't really uh know
they also said that his car was
repainted uh not long after the accident
they he repainted it red so again that's
a little sus but like I said they don't
think this dude killed anybody they just
think that he was at the scene and maybe
well they know that he hit the car a
little bit because they found the paint
but they don't know if that caused the
accident like if the accident would have
happened anyway and he just happened to
be there was like [__] this I'm just
going they don't know you know what I
mean because there was no cameras
yeah so remember how I said earlier
about that whole bright flash thing yeah
um that's a whole other uh conspiracy
theory that the C that the crash was
actually caused by somebody um perhaps
the Secret Service again was like
flashing bright lights at the driver of
the car like to make him lose control of
the car the bright flash conspiracy yeah
that's the whole thing well because
allegedly at least three Witnesses said
that they saw a very bright flash on the
outside of the tunnel um prior to the
crash
occurring uh
so so there has been some things and and
like I said going back to what uh
Tomlinson said earlier about oh that's
how they MI6 were talking about like
assassinating the Serbian dude like by
Flash and bright lights or strobe lights
I think they said strobe lights but
strobe lights at the driver of the
person's car and then like causing them
to lose control yeah kind of like he
can't hit the brakes and slow down well
yeah I just they thought will it' be so
like
disorienting you know what I mean
doesn't work that way yeah but you know
what I mean so as far as I know um I
think only like three or four Witnesses
said they saw that and like some people
that were in the car with some of the
witnesses said yeah I didn't see that
[__] so it's like I don't really know
like how much um weight I want to give
to that uh and again that goes back to
it seems like a really convoluted way to
like kill somebody let me say something
yeah over the years things have been
Declassified from back in the [__]
40s 50s actually not so much 40s but 50s
60s of [__]
that spook types have [__] come up
withit ways to kill other
people the thing is they never actually
used those for the most part on a few
occasions I think some Soviet guy shot a
damn pellet into somebody's [__] back
of somebody's
leg in it or something using an air gun
that looked like a [__] pair of
umbrella look like an umbrella yeah yeah
[__] like that that did happen yeah that
did happen couple times but a lot of
these weird convoluted things about
[__] bouncing [__] weird
microwaves off of people's heads to make
them go crazy and
[__]
look man being exmilitary ex infantry
and
everything what actually works in combat
to kill somebody is something really
practical that's what actually works
these gimmicks and gizmos and
[__] the chances of you actually scoring
a victory which that's we call it
scoring a victory you guys call killing
somebody chances of scoring a victory
with some kind of [__] exotic
[__] very low and you're why am I
going through all this I could just grab
that dude put him in a sleeper hole and
[__] choke him out kill
him that's I all of these kind of like
complicated like com I'm like yeah
aren't there much easier ways to
accomplish to do this [__] why do you
have to so uh the [__] in spy Spy
manuals and spy novels it makes a good
it makes a good story no like it's
exciting and [__] but what actually
works in
spycraft is knowing how to lie knowing
how to lie using [__] [__] closest to
the truth so your lies Sound
True um to twist the mind of somebody
who you're working with or working
against costume
changes you did something you're in a
certain amount of clothes you go to the
restroom real quick with a plastic bag
and you come out the plastic bag and now
you got different clothes on and [__]
you look totally different but the thing
is you got to be a person to get that
right it's that camouflage really to get
that right you got to be a person who's
totally average when it comes to
physical build somebody that's just you
don't notice
them I couldn't get away with [__] like
that they would notice me but just my
height alone and and I'm
bald Shay bald in my build
[__] there's been a bunch of
demonstrations of this before
how it's similar to kind of like the
basketball players and the [__]
gorilla gorilla walking across that's a
very famous yeah very much like that
where you see a crowd of people going in
and out of a place and you didn't see
anything unusual but what happened is is
like half of those people were the same
people they changed their clothes right
you know or did little things here and
there so uh spies do [__] like that but
there I mean me and you would not make
good spies because like everywhere we go
people remember yeah yeah cuz we like
really stick out nothing that sticks out
and a lot of the spycraft from that era
was Cold War era you don't need it
anymore because [__] and you have the
internet and the internet you don't need
to [__] drop physically drop
information off into a public bathroom
so somebody else can [__] come and
get nowadays put in the toilet T yeah
put yeah you don't have to do now
nowadays you just [__] go on Xbox One
and [__] you're playing a video game
where everybody's playing a multiplayer
video game and you're talking to the
other players and you're talking to the
other spy in the game yeah because
nobody's watching that I'll be over
there next Mar okay okay you you got the
money I got the money do you have the
stuff I you I got the stuff we'll do the
exchange [__] over at IHOP tomorrow
okay I'll see you there it's
just well stuff like I said it's stuff
that no one would notice you have to
keep every that's the whole point is
like to keep everything on the down yeah
and then you're in a room and [__]
shooting each other up in a [__] Call
of Duty video game and there's [__]
30 dudes who heard you say that and they
have no idea what you're talking about
yeah and no other intell because you're
not trying to be sneaky the second you
try to be sneaky then it's suspicious
okay talking if you're just talking
about [__] in the open no one's going to
think about anything because you're not
trying to be nefarious or some of you
guys going oh that's [__] Noah no a
lot of SF was killing people in
Afghanistan and they were talking about
it in Call of Duty video games live yeah
to each other because no one would
suspect that no one would suspect well
now they would they're playing VA there
tomorrow yeah Mission will be tomorrow
we'll take out [__] Target a and two
uh uh Target a A2 and [__] 4 B we'll
see you [__] 400 you know 1300 hours
tomorrow okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah we'll get this over with and it's
just [__] like that and the other
players have no idea what these guys are
talking about those dudes are in
Afghanistan talking about [__]
striking a Target tomorrow yeah you know
and [__] what are the afghanis going
to do what they got [__] the afghanis
have their own secret agents listening
into all of the [__] live video games
happening on Xbox One and No never
they they speak pashon or some [__] like
that they don't speak English so you
don't need any of that it's not the it's
not the Soviet Cold War anymore
technology like I said that does make
better stories I will admit yeah yeah
it's just stories most of the Spy [__]
now is just like boring yeah if you
would you wouldn't want you wouldn't
want to watch a movie about that because
it'd be boring technology has made all
that [__] boring
now PO says and this is something I
agree with people love Diana
conspiracies are A coping mechanism
yeah I think I didn't say that exact
thing but like early on in the show I I
said I was like anytime and we did a
show a couple weeks back about rock and
roll conspiracies about Jimmy Hendricks
and all that kind of stuff and I was
like anytime somebody that Larger than
Life
dies um people are going to think well
they can't have just choked on their own
vomit they can't have just died in a
stupid car accident they can't it just
doesn't seem like that just can't happen
they're you know they're above us
they're like bigger than they're like a
god almost so when something just like
dumb and avoidable like happens to them
then people's like there had to be more
to it I kind of feel like that's a lot
of what's going on yeah yeah people
don't accept it they just yeah you don't
accept it but like I said they're just
people they could die in Stupid Ways
just like the rest of us like ACDC Bon
Scott died in the back of the limousine
choking on his own vom poor guy you know
what I mean they happen it could happen
to anybody it happen to anybody it could
happen to anybody it didn't it wasn't
any any conspiracy behind it just
because they're famous and Ren and like
legendary doesn't mean that they're not
just a person they replaced [__] Bob
Scott with Brian Johnson a [__]
I think was I mean he was different but
man just as good if not better you
know [__] ACDC [__] that was one
one of Australia's greatest gifts that
was just a [__] band about getting
drunk getting drunk and getting laid it
was that stupid and the [__] worked and
every album was like that getting drunk
and getting late are both are both fun
like ACDC was the [__] they're both fun
things I advocate for both of those
things so uh okay so the last thing that
we're going to cover about um The
Conspiracy thing and this I kind of get
it um I get where they're coming from
but again I don't think there's anything
to ferious in it people have complained
that um it took too long to get Diana to
the hospital because I don't know people
know I mean probably they know um doie
fed and hory Paul uh were both dead at
the scene uh of the accident however uh
Trevor ree Jones was obviously was still
alive he's still alive today he survived
the accident which with relatively minor
injuries Diana was also still alive um
it took them a while to cut her out of
the car because like I said if you've
seen pictures of the car it was pretty
much annihilated so that it took a while
for them to cut her
out now when they got her out of the car
they put her in the ambulance and
started working on her in there because
that is and I think a lot of people
freaked out because the way that
different countries deal with
emergencies are slightly different they
have different protocols in the UK as
you know from what I understand um you
know the ambulance comes to the scene of
the accident they put the person in the
ambulance and they try to get them to
the nearest hospital like as quickly as
possible um which is how some countries
do it in France uh you know they have
the ambulance there they said they will
try to work as much as they can on the
person in the ambulence uh you know they
will try to stabilize them they will try
to do what they can do and then they
will go to a hospital but they'll go to
the hospital that they think is the best
hospital whether it's the nearest one or
not so I think that like a lot of people
were upset because you know they worked
on her a while like I said it took a
while for them to cut her out of the car
she was still alive they put her in the
ambulance and they worked on the
ambulance which was protocol for you
know what the french Emergency Services
would do so they got her kind of
stabilized um and they went kind of slow
because they were afraid that like her
blood pressure was like erratic and they
didn't want to like you know mess
anything up so they went kind of slow
they didn't go to the nearest hospital
because they were afraid um at least
according to the doctors and stuff like
that they're like well the hospital
that's the closest they don't have the
facilities to deal with um injuries of
this magnitude so we need to go to this
next Hospital which was farther away so
a lot of people uh kind of freaked out
about that cuz they said well had she
you know been brought to the closer
hospital maybe she could have been saved
or something like that I don't know if
that's the case though because by the
time yes it did take them a while to get
them to to get her to the other hospital
by the time they got there she was still
alive uh when she got to the other
hospital but and they did fix they said
that she had a really unusual um one of
the uh the veins like in her heart was
ruptured they did fix it but by the time
they fixed it it was really too late to
save her they're like her injuries were
just too uh you were just too Grievous
um there wasn't really anything they
could do they spent like four hours
trying to revive her trying to like fix
it trying to bring it back and they just
couldn't do it like her injuries were
just too bad so I don't know like I said
you can't go back and relive the past
and say oh if she'd been taken to the
closer hospit they were just worried
that the closer hospital didn't have the
the facilities they needed they wanted
this particular surgeon who specialized
in her kinds of injuries and they
thought that it would be better to take
it a little bit farther and go to this
little bit farther one you know they
thought she'd have her the best chance
and they had all the [__] in the
ambulance they were working on her the
ambulance too but a lot of people have
said oh well they wanted her to die
because they would have gone to the
closer one but I don't know if I believe
that no it wouldn't have made a
difference Princess Diana was wasn't
physically built like a tank okay she
was just a very average woman a very
average bill she took a lot of damage
there's only so much you can
do you know [__] you you you do
massive trauma to a person they gonna
die just yeah I mean that's the thing
yeah I'm not saying it was the wisest
decision maybe they should have taken
her to the closest hospital that's
normally what they would
do probably wouldn't have made a
difference I'm not yeah and like I said
there's no way of going back in time and
checking like if it would have come out
differently uh apparently her injuries
were pretty bad so I don't really know I
don't know see because like I said
there's a lot of conspiracy theories
about that too because a lot of the
early reports because like I said there
were Paparazzi and [__] there like
taking pictures of the [__] and they
were there on the ground and they were
getting some news some of the early
reports were that Diana wasn't hurt that
badly that she was just like had a broke
her leg or something like that that she
wasn't that [__] up but I don't know
having seen the
car I I'm actually amazed that anybody
survived that [__] because it was like
[__] it was [__] up and the only
reason that Trevor ree Jones survived I
think was because he had a seat belt on
and nobody else did yeah and that was
kind of one of the things they came up
with too because everybody was just like
flying around the car they said there's
blood everywhere High Desert refers back
to me talking about the things say the
will of Taliban W in the end anyway see
he must be ex military yeah they won in
the end anyway because the [__]
pentagon's stupid they don't realize
well starting to realize that culture
beats the [__] out of any strategy you
cannot [__] conquer you you cannot
conquer a culture unless you're willing
to just annihilate that entire culture
and they're not willing to do that that
was not what they were there
for okay let's see what you guys are
saying while she taking the break she's
walking out there you should have seen
it man she looked beautiful
too Camp guy said my wife had a total
respiratory arrest
was it respiratory arrest and a and the
respiratory therapist told me she was
very lucky we lived near a large
emergency
room where they had a lot of [__]
experience with that
stuff I think that's a different
situation though because D was [__]
she was pretty [__] crushed
up I remember seeing photographs of it
when when I was younger back in
'97 and uh no she was in bad condition
and when you have trauma like
that sometimes there's just nothing you
can do I you know I mean if you find
somebody they're just blown apart or
they're just [__]
crushed you're not going to be able to
save them doesn't matter what you do
they're they're dying you
know well yeah okay what you could do
[__] suck them up with a damn Star
Trek transporter put them back together
the way they should then just ret
teleport them that would work but you
can't do that with modern techn with the
technology we have today some people
just are so talking about a teleporter
yeah so you can't fix everybody that
gets hurt yeah that's what I mean like
sometimes it's just too bad it's just
too bad the only way to fix somebody
like that' be like on Star Trek where
you beam them up and then when their
particles rearrange them and then beam
them back hole you could that'll fix
them but we don't have the technology
but we don't have that yet so it's like
so I I don't know um most of you guys
know cuz we've done shows about other
conspiracies before too oh he said nice
bulge yeah yeah yeah it's a nice bulge
it is a nice bulge
yeah I will test but um [__] fun
[__] it's nice what's under
that bulge J James said that that's like
see you you [__] watch James you [__]
watch I well you know all right man man
can appreciate you a meat gazer no I
understand L that [__] understand he's
like looking at bodybuilding dudes the
time yeah he looks he looks at
bodybuilding chicks to yeah too yeah I
look at people like their animals like
their horses or something like I was
back in the horse business deal with
thorough Breads and [__] I'm looking
about [__] definition where the
insertions are what kind of mass you
have here and there yeah he's looking
like at you like you're like a [__]
like you're a cow like you're a side of
beef hanging on the [__] yeah I'm trying
to estimate how strong a dude is by
looking at his arms and stuff Allison
says Jenny Quick be a [__]
blockers but yeah so that's the thing
and I think we've talked about this
before
um a lot of these conspir especially
these ones I kind of feel like I'm not
saying conspiracy theories like some of
them aren't true or you know partially
true because some of them
are you know but I'm just saying that
one the larger a conspiracy is the more
people that have to be involved the less
likely I think that it happened the way
the people say that it happened because
it's just one it's too complicated two
too many people involved uh somebody
would blab and it's just it's too much
and it's and it's too much [__] that
could because okay for example like
Diana if they wanted to knock her off
they could have done it easily in a
myriad of other ways and a long time
before this and a long and doing
something like oh we're gonna make this
dude get drunk or we're GNA pretend he
got drunk or he's gonna like you know
drive a car into like a [__] uh you
know pillar under a tunnel and kill her
that could go wrong in numerous ways why
would you do something that contingent
upon [__] you couldn't control yeah I
don't really understand and like I said
and I've written about like other
murders that people thought were like oh
my God like the CIA bumped this person
off and [__] like that but when you look
at the things it's like why like look if
I was a CIA and I wanted to like
assassinate somebody just allegedly like
you know just
theoretically there's ways you could do
that that it would still look like an
accident or like they off themselves or
something like that that wouldn't draw
so much attention why would you do
something one this public yeah to um
this in in this way that could go wrong
in a lot of ways like what if she didn't
die what if she wasn't hurt at all what
if the car didn't crash what if all
because there's so many other factors
there's other people on the road there's
other [__] going on it just seems like a
dumb way to do it if you're going to do
it tell I'm going to tell you all the
main ways to do
it the two traditional ways to do it is
[__] you go into the target's place
of work or where they live and you got
five guys you grab the dude open the
window and toss them out the
window they stopped doing that because
skyscrapers now no longer have any
windows that open because they're all
Central for that reason well that too
right toss them out and they you say
well it's suicide yeah they just jumped
out which like I said seems honestly I
think and I'm not don't do this but I'm
just saying the probably the best way
yeah take somebody on a hiking vacation
and just go Boop and like push him off
the mountain second way that they do it
is uh five or six guys come in on the
guy as friends and wherever he is he
might know one of them or they're there
under a
ruse each one of them grabs a limb they
pick him up they [__] it's kind of
like an arrest they handcuff him they
put him in a vehicle and they take him
out somewhere somewhere where they hang
him okay and then they say it's a
suicide they'll even [__] throw down
a suicide note not in his writing right
and that's that's that's usually enough
now the way my friend used to do it Tim
I just told him about for name is Tim
vacus or Timothy mag he's like shut up
man why are you talking about well he's
in he's in prison right
now the way they would do it is that the
client would provide them and this is in
Central and South America the the Cent
would provide
them
with real police uniforms and a police
vehicle and they they would go to the
target's home with an arrest warrant it
the arrest warrant would be totally fake
they'd arrest that person then take them
out to a pre-planned location where the
hole was already dug they'd shoot him in
the back of the head throw him in the
hole cover him up yeah because then like
no one they were never found find them
yeah that's what a death squad does and
Tim ran a death Squad it was him a
couple of Russian guys a German ex a
couple of they were all EX soldiers Tim
was like a
E8 or E7 which you know E7 was a master
sergeant that's what he was when he
that's what he ended up when he left
service I knew him when he was a [__]
E1 we went to basic together [__]
served in the 506 and [__] in the
101st Airborne
Division and um got out as a I think it
was E7 and then went into the
Contracting
world and his team I think was seven or
eight guys they were all ex-military EX
German military ex poolish military
ex-russian military guys and they worked
Central and South America they worked
for their clients were elected officials
in those
governments okay and CIA was evidently
involved also because the guys that they
were working for were under the orders
of of central intelligence agency
evidently so they say rumor has
it okay and what you trying to do the
reason why they're doing that is they're
trying to get select individuals into
certain offices where who in these guys
are PSIs or not pis [__] what do you
call them
uh not py what do you call it when you
get somebody it's a plant uh somebody
who listens to what you say he's a
compromised dude you got mole not even a
mole uh what do you call the [__]
dudes you put a guy into
office who you've been grooming for a
long time to get him in there and you
got a lot of dirt on him he'll do
exactly what you say and you're bribing
him like a Manu candidate no kind of
yeah and it's and it's [__] done at a
military level there's a lot puppet says
Mr what's that Mr ad says puppet puppet
that's a good way to put yeah puppet
you're trying to install yeah I said
you're trying to install that's not
quite the same though you're trying to
install puppet that's easy to
control and usually the controllers are
not in that country usually the
controllers are in the United States or
they're in some kind of a
multinational government organization
like the UN or some [__] like that
that's who you're trying to get
in James says do you think the royal
family are reptilians in di found out
they K because man they got Fork tongues
red eyes right out of it's right out of
they might as well like I don't think
they're actual reptilians didn't we do a
show about I think we did a show about
like Illuminati and reptilians and stuff
like that which was the fun show David
yeah D yeah is it icky does he really
want does I think it's Ike does he
really want his last
name I don't know yeah I'm not I'm not
sure I'm never sure like I've seen some
of that dude's stuff I think it's
metaphor I'm like is that dude really
crazy or is he crazy for dollars you
know what I mean as in I'm going come up
with this crazy [__] CU I know dumb
asses will buy it my take my take on you
can never tell these days my T my take
on David ik Ike or iy or whatever is
that it's
uh
he's using
metaphor he's saying they're lizard like
people and he's doing this all right I'm
on board with that but I think what he's
just saying is that they're corrupt the
corrupted people but he can't come out
and say that for his own protection he's
trying to throw up [__] camouflage
deniability by saying well no they're
they're
actually
reptilians that was a document yeah
that's what they are and I think that's
what he's doing to cover his own ass so
if he ever gets in illegal trouble he
goes oh I'm crazy or you know I'm just
making this [__] up they're not reptiles
that might be I think that's what he's
talking about like some of the crazy
[__] that people come up with and you're
like oh my God how could anybody believe
in that maybe they don't really but
they're just like well we want to say
this but we can't come out and say that
in trouble so we're going to say
something that makes it sound like we're
crazy yeah but people will get so that
we have plausible plausible diability
that's what I that's that was my take on
him I think I think what he was talking
about was globalists and the world
economic form what he's talking about
basically if you're James Bond's fan
he's talking about Spectre that's what
Spectre is in Spectre wasn't something
just pulled out of nowhere it was
[__] Ian flaming and Ian flaming was
involved in the early versions of the
CIA you know and in in the World War II
era but like I said that quite doesn't
that doesn't quite apply anymore but Ian
Fleming was talking about
non-governmental organizations and gangs
of
oligarchs
like Club of Rome is mostly what he was
talking about back in those days and
those exist man gangs of oligarchs exist
[__] well yeah you get all that money
they're get together and like do [__]
United States was built by him man the
[__] JP Morgan the [__]
Rockefellers [__] yeah it was all
those people were kind of shitty and
they were bad yeah I don't even want to
say kind of shitty they were all they
were [__] they were all pretty shitty
pretty shitty all pretty shitty well
they did build the infrastructure of the
country but they killed a lot of people
do sure but like I
said the way they looked at it well you
[__] make an omelette you got to
break some eggs that's the way they they
were ruthless that's exactly the way
yeah they killed a lot of people killed
a lot people and they were [__]
mowing down Chinese and [__] Chinese
railroad workers and [__] Irish oh you
want more money oh no yeah well they
were [__] revolting bury you
somewhere and no one knows where you're
burying yeah they don't even they don't
even know exactly why were all these
Irish bodies and all these Chinese
bodies buried along this railroad was
that duh why do you we don't know well
we don't know we don't have any records
well they're going to tell you that the
railroads the US railroads at the time
had the ability to pass the death
sentence they had their own cour they
could pass the death sentence on on
their own employees that's messed up
okay that is messed up corporations are
dangerous and they kind of ran the
United States they owned the United
States oh yeah so all this [__] about
[__] whan industries from Alien and
[__] yeah that's actually what yeah
that's actually what you're talking
about like in a lot of ways like people
[__] about it now it's it's bad now I'm
not saying it but it was probably worse
back then because it's just they killed
people and just like buried them and
they probably still don't know where
they're buried at yeah they had private
armies and everything like the p and
[__] and all kinds of stuff they just
mowed people down they they did not give
a single [__] people think it's bad now
it is bad but it was even worse they did
not give a single [__] yeah no such
thing as good old days that's what I
always say they single just because
somebody says that they're a part of the
medical industry and the doctors and
[__] same [__] thing the US Med
medical industry made profit off of
patented medicine patent medicine
involved poison mostly they just [__]
profiteering profiteering and more
profiteering it's not about curing
disease it's about treating things with
expensive
treatments like their cures for diabetes
have appeared several times and they
purchased that [__] up [__] kept use
gene therapy to cure that yeah hormones
can do it too but they don't want they
make so much money off insulin they need
diabetes they're addicted to that they
make a [__] ton of money off of
it so just cuz you have somebody saying
well we're the am community and [__]
you can pay off a doctor or the AMA was
[__] bought off by the damn drug
Industries so basically you're dealing
with like something out of Idiocracy
where [__] brondo owns everything and
brondo is [__] feeding the plants
brondo because electrolytes is what
plants grave you know that's what's
happening
here well like I said it's like you know
can I have another yeah yeah I'll make
another one but I'm just saying that um
yeah I mean as bad as it is now and it
is bad but at least nowadays most people
have a
conception of people being like valuable
as individuals I kind of feel like back
then they didn't really have that
because they were just kind of like look
if you're not from our race or your poor
or something like that they're just like
ah we'll just kill him there's more they
like they've literally probably didn't
even think about it which now they might
feel a little bit bad maybe I don't
really know but back then they did not
because they were just like ah these are
just PE people working on our railroads
they're immigrants or they're poor or
they're whatever it's like if they're
doing some [__] we don't like we're just
going to kill them and bury them out in
the desert someplace and nobody will
ever find them yeah you know they did
that [__] they did that [__] they might
do it now I don't know but it would be
harder to get away with nowadays well
like I said I do kind of feel like
nowadays people do have most people do
have a conception of people being
valuable as individuals yeah where I
kind of feel like they didn't really
have that as much all right in the late
19th early 20th century I've analyzed
this over and over again I came from
kind of like on the right but then I
realized that that's also fake um what's
happening now has nothing to do with the
1930s and [__] the rise of the bent
cross mustache Min has nothing to
[__] do with that we're not in an era
like that we're more like in an era of
the
1600s with the invention of the printing
press and it's tearing apart the church
it is very much like and more like that
and people can now read the Bible and
understand a new translations of it
that's more like that now yeah not
exactly but that's a good analogy what's
tearing the system apart is the
internet because the lies no longer work
and the old the old um institutions like
universities and [__] legal systems
none of that [__] is [__] relevant
anymore you can go to university all you
want come out and still not get a job
because they're not going to teach you
anything you can learn some [__] on the
internet to make a living what do you
need them for you know [__] a girl
can go out and [__] work stream mate
and [__] make a living somebody can
get you think my ass is doing yeah they
can't and these universities can't teach
you anything anymore really they can
teach you science
you can might be able to make money from
that but that's only a small amount of
people this whole idea where millions of
people going to universities to get
these [__] expensive degrees to go
out and get a job that's gone that's
gone you're better off in the trades if
you're a man [__] become a plumber or
an electrician you'll you'll make a
living well a woman can do that too you
a woman could do that too but you're not
going to make a living working in an
office I tried that my brother's an
electrician did you know that no yeah
that's good jobs man trades is where it
where it's that's really where it's at
it's very stable you're always going to
need those guys but man I worked in an
office too as a [__] salesman doing
[__] and [__] that [__] [__] went
away but then you come a street
salesman you know and that's good but
all that [__] went away eventually
eventually [__] construction might go
away I don't think it will but
construction is being outsourced to to
[__] illegal to [__] like illegal
aliens basically in some states well I
would
advise um
to either learn something that can't
be
uh interne ised yeah um you know be a be
a chef or some [__] like that everybody
people got to eat a physical [__] like
yeah something like that or um be real
adaptable like learn how to Pivot yeah
you got to like just um crank out and
like [__] find some [__] online and
just do a bunch of that I mean like said
that's kind of what I'm doing if you're
young it's very stressful but yeah it
can be done if you're young you're
living in a world of
Lies when I was young they promised us a
bunch of [__] all right they never
appeared they said they told us and
[__] gther isn't isn't in here today
I have not seen him today we went to
high school together [__] our
teachers back in the 8S were telling us
well and we were in the Detroit era in
area where all the [__] Automotive
industries were for GM they were selling
us manufacturing uh [__] is obsolete
we're going to get rid of manufacturing
we're gonna we're going to make our
we've outgrown that we're going to let
countries like China do that what we're
going to do is we're going to become a
service industry well we're all work at
these damn restaurants and these little
businesses and [__] uh uh indoors it's a
much better work we don't have we don't
have to get your hands greasy and you
can got to go down to the cold you can
work in air conditioning and you don't
have to [__] work on a factory line
or you don't have to work out in the
field with the black people and the
brown people that's really [__] what
they were actually telling yeah they
didn't say that out loud but that's what
they were telling okay well guess what
all those
[__] all the service Industries jobs
[__] lasted not even a decade and
then they be ended up becoming all
[__] minimum that's what I mean you
never know what's going to happen so you
have to be like really adapt these were
all lies because the hardcore capitalist
industrialists and the hardcore
corporatist really I don't like to bag
on capitalism because people don't
really know what capitalism this is
corporatism the corporatist just
outsourced all the job in China because
it was cheaper and has made more profit
they don't want to pay our assets they
want to pay us because we will'll form a
union and if you form a union you not
have to pay somebody oh now we have
rights too and we got to pay you and
they talking about [__] that we don't
want to pay you people give any benefits
or nothing there's okay you guys are
going to sit here and ask for a bunch of
wages we'll just open up the borders and
flood the [__] place with poor people
to compete against you man your minimum
wage starts to and then you got all
these political parties both the
Republicans and the Democrats
gaslighting oh no nothing's everything's
fine everything matter of fact we're
going to give [__] corporate welfare
and we're going to give a bunch of tax
breaks to all the corporations then
slowly all the money being sucked up
into that [__] top 1% and who are
those dudes old dudes with sex Silence
with underage girls from Florida on
that's who that's what you're dealing
with I remember reading a quote I can't
remember like a book I read a long time
ago but they said it's like yeah uh
wealth does not trickle down wealth is
sucked up it's sucked up and the money
pump is turned on and it's sucking all
the money out of us yeah and it's going
up yeah they could give me some back
just a little bit yep that'd be
nice that'd be nice [__] him well we
just got to survive that's what I mean
and it's just kind of like here's here's
here here's the Silver Lining it's not
sustainable it's this [__] it's
happening now that's why I don't worry
too much about it like I worry but I
don't worry when you look through
history when you see what's happening
now what tends to happen is a Revolt a
[__] populist Revolt the ruling
classes [__] runs they run to other
countries for safety and then it kind of
reboots and it kind of goes back to a
more Fair system it's just they got to
figure out who the leaders of the
Revolution are and what fair is you know
and fair is you should be paid for your
work you know and uh you should have a
government that protects you and your
job and your livelihood so you could
have children because if you have
children there's a replacement
population because people don't live
forever shit's better for everybody when
everybody has a a decent standard right
right right like you should be able to
like have a job and have a house and
have money to have a family if you want
to and it's just kind of and not worry
about oh [__] my electricity is going to
get turned off I'm going to get kicked
out of my house it's like you know what
I mean it's like people behave a lot
better yeah just you know in aggregate
when they're not worried about where is
my next meal coming from and if you're
foreign you can say well what what
exactly you're talking about okay go
back to old
movies old Steven Spielberg movies okay
when you see what the American family is
supposed to live like in Close
Encounters of the Third Kind imp piz it
was basic good
[__] anybody anywhere on the earth if
they live like that they'd be happy the
kids go to school you live in a
neighborhood [__] there's police
services nobody's killing each other you
got good food you have good
entertainment there's for you to no yeah
do anything bad right you have
everything and there's always a promise
of upward Mobility right that you can
actually if you work harder get more
that's not the system now working more
actually doesn't give you more it's not
really worth it what gives you cheating
more cheating more gets you more I hate
to say but yeah that you know but that's
I hate to say it but that's kind [__]
over people gets you more yeah but not
working and that shouldn't be the way
hell no it is that shouldn't be the way
it is no and that was the way Brazil was
Brazil was like this the more you [__]
over other people the more you'd move up
it was just extreme corrup and that's
[__] up because I like I I can't do
that to other people I just can't I
won't yeah and so and I a lot of people
won't all right you know what I mean so
it's just kind of like I don't that's a
bad that's a that's a non-sustainable
situ America and Europe are set on easy
the difficulty is set on easy Brazil was
set on
Expert it was just hard and you had to
not to lie it's basically the Star Trek
Mirror
Universe when I see all that Mirror
Universe I was like oh yeah yeah okay
like South America yeah because that's
all South America well they probably did
their research honestly yeah they knew
what they and not to talk bad about
South America loves South and Central
America he loved Brazil I love it yeah
those are great people strong people he
thrives in that type of situation yeah
kind of like a Tom does yeah in a
[__] I probably would not like it I
would like to visit there I'm not L I'm
not lying we'll go one I thrive I thrive
in basically in what what experts would
call an an anarco tyranny I [__]
where yeah Tom loves that [__] yeah you
have a tyrannical government that does
whatever it wants and but it's in an
anarchy where there's laws but nobody's
obeying them yeah so in a way that's
like your favorite thing yeah because
it's [__] free
in a weird way Brazil was a lot more
free than the United States of Europe
you could do whatever you wanted yeah
yeah whether it was legal or not it
didn't matter like Colombia yeah I love
that
[__] because a man just just do what the
[__] he wants yeah you know if you have
the money and the skills to get away
with it and you can do it yeah I read
ancient Roman [__] history and I go
yeah like Brazil yeah because a man is
mostly judged by
his ability to protect his friends and
his family and his ability to punish his
enemies because the state's not going to
do it you know what I mean the the
justice system can't do it you have to
do it this Mafia thinking you know
basically me and you will go to Brazil
one day oh you'll love Brazil but my
friends that are still there say don't
go right now just say it's [__]
terrible well yeah I don't want to get
killed or nothing I'm just saying that
it's like I would like to go though yeah
all ask [__] L and you speak
Portuguese so it's F yeah I'm I don't
but and I got friends over there still
[__] I grew up with gone yeah if you
didn't know he's bilingual actually yeah
gast's still down there londo's still
there [__] and uh we we go hang out
with
them and they they have wives they
married [__] hot wives and everything
got kids we were the heavy metal
Brazilian heavy metal kids I wouldn't
believe it those dudes got hot wives
they were fat boys when I knew them they
[__] trimmed up got hot [__] hot
Brazilian wives and good-looking kids
castel's got [__] his daughter is a
[__] an 8.5 she looks like a [__]
Brazilian supermodel he's rating people
I never would have yeah I rate people I
look at people like their sides of beef
and [__] now G's his little daughter to
beef am I yeah yeah no's daughter's like
in her early 20s and she she would here
in the United States she'd be a super
model murder Hornet said damn y'all
still going yeah has been that long it's
only it's only three hours three hours
okay it's a long show that's all right
we're having a good time how much more
we got left that's pretty much it pretty
much it okay I mean I was talking about
the hospital [__] you know what I mean
that was pretty much it like I said I
saw the thing going down in
some I do not think that anybody killed
dianae I think it was just a stupid
accident that probably could have been
avoided um but you know [__] happens it
happens to the best of us whether we're
super famous or whether we're awesome
people or whatever which is just kind of
like and and I've said this before too
and again I think this is the root of a
lot of conspiracy theories also I think
a lot of people have a hard time with
Randomness they don't like the fact that
oh my God that was like an awesome
person or that was a super famous person
or that was like you know whatever that
was like a really a virtuous person or
whatever there's no way they could have
died like that but I was just like you
know what um the universe doesn't care
sadly um and that's kind of a hard thing
for people to deal with I don't like to
think about it but it's it's true well
compared to the it happens all the time
we've known people that were awesome
people yeah pretty as [__] that got
cancer yeah and died and died when they
were like [__] 30 something yeah so
yeah we've known girls that were um hot
as
[__] in their 20s
like a Gothic supermodel and then it
turned out whatever happened to that
girl oh she died yeah died of a drug
overdose yep just just stupid [__] yeah
but like I said it happens there's no
reason yeah there's no but like I said I
think people have a hard time with a um
with a universe that's indifferent yeah
no matter how awesome you are you ain't
[__] compared to the universe it doesn't
even notice you that's what I mean and
it I
mean I don't know I think I've kind of
um I don't I don't know if I necessarily
have made my piece with that because I
don't like it but it's just kind of like
then I'm like well the universe doesn't
care if I like it or not because the
universe doesn't give a single fart
about me at all I believe in a Quantum
after World though I've seen it through
near-death
experiences our bodies die we actually
don't die our point of view goes goes on
you're not exactly the same person
anymore you're a lot less you're smaller
you're just like a point of view and
then you reincarnate I
believe that seemed to be POS I mean or
you go you could go but you're resting
outside the time I mean I'm not sure I
believe that but you just have to see
yourself I don't know maybe I'm not I'm
not denying it that Acid Trip right it's
similar to that it's similar to
that yeah you're not just right just
like what Yoda
said luminous beings are we not this
crude matter that that's exactly true
yeah there's more to us than but when
you
die your
character you know Jennifer it it's gone
you remember it but that's not you
anymore that was just a role you were
playing yeah what you really are is more
like just a point of view you going to
hang out and look for me in the
afterlife yeah if it matters though I'm
not sure that it matters because you
won't give you won't give a [__] about
me because well see what it is you're
like the connection was from a past life
not a present life it was like a role
like you playing a video game yeah
playing a video game and the character
you're playing you got killed well you
start a new game yeah you don't remember
the past lives that much you don't
because they're not that important
because there's a bit there's a whole
universe going on and everybody's doing
that yeah you know but when that one
time when I basically died in that
motorcycle accident there was a greeting
there was a welcoming committee there of
a bunch of people male and
female that were I don't know even what
time zones they were from they were just
ancient
wise friends of
mine now I don't know if they
were alternate life lifetimes that maybe
they were all me right or characters
that I or they were other people you
know but the thing is is that you're
outside
SpaceTime so you're talking about infiny
infinity infinity yeah Infinity close
enough so just a 40 you know 70y year
lifespan is nothing and then you're
dealing with [__] aliens and [__]
like that alien Souls my thing though is
that I always kind of feel like well
just in case there's not anything like
that going on after you die before you
die whatever it is um I'm just going to
like try and make the most out of this
[__] because I don't know if there's any
more after that so I'm just going to
like
[__] party in this [__] because I
don't know I I don't get the thing it's
like ah you know it's like well if this
life sucked then maybe the next one will
be better I'm like yeah but you don't
know that yeah well make the most out of
this [__] because you don't know if
that's you know what I mean here's
something else I could can
contribute when I had that nde the
people that welcomed
me were all from from Earth they were
all Earth people they weren't
aliens so maybe that maybe that
means you're being reincarnated you're
inside of the Earth's
biosphere you know what I mean sure
something about your soul
doesn't maybe it was created here so it
stays here it doesn't go to other
planets but they're
there yeah I don't know I'm not so they
have their souls over there you know I'm
just worried about I'm just worried
about this it was just weird yeah like I
said because I don't all of that is a
hypothetical yeah so I just kind of like
worry about this [__] right here yeah
and I think that's kind of like a expi
that well I know you do but I I know you
did but I'm just saying even if I had um
I would think to myself being Spock
likee as I am well that might have just
been a dream or or some other thing so
it's like well I would think that so I
was just kind of like well I don't know
if that was real or not
so I'm just going to assume that um
whatever I have going on here this is it
so I have to like make the most of
whatever is going on well play yeah run
it that and I think that's like the best
way to go yeah I think that's the best
way to go about things cuz I was like I
I don't really like this whole thing
it's like oh it'll be better like after
I die I'm like [__] that I don't know
that when you die you'll be surprise
though you'll be like oh okay not
actually yeah I'm willing to I'm willing
to go with that it's if it's a surprise
that's cool I'm cool with that I was
under the impression now looking back on
it everybody I saw was from Earth yeah
some of them were real ancient or they
might have been futuristic but they just
seemed ancient but
uh because I think they were from other
times people that were talking to me so
it could be
that life creates these souls and they
evolve here around this biosphere until
you become more more conscious more you
grow more and more you probably were
animals in the past too
and you probably stay in this area you
don't reincarnate as an alien you know
what I mean right that's a different
biosphere that's maybe that would be
kind of weird if that happened you just
stay around this biosphere sure because
this is where you would belong so it
might be that but you just got me
thinking about that
now under the influence of alcohol but
that might have been what it what that
means is that your soul was created here
when life first started to evolve
millions of years ago billions of years
ago maybe um so so your your life force
is a creation of this planet so you're
Earth
Centric which would mean other planets
that have life have their own spiritual
realm or Quantum realm that's around
them of [__] life forces evolving up
through their [__] biospheres to
become more and more conscious so there
are alien Souls you just don't you just
don't really mix with them because you
don't know about them so you can't
teleport over there yeah because you
could teleport to any place you know of
or can think
of from yeah from experience we were
talking about
um people dying randomly and stuff yeah
Tammy said my son died at age 11 from a
heart problem yeah which yeah I think
you've told us that before and that is
awful and she says um been many years
ago but you know thank you for the yeah
that's that's messed up like I said
we've
known many people that died far before
their time in their 20s and 30s and it's
just there's
no there's no sense to it and you'll
make yourself crazy trying to make sense
of it because there isn't any and I know
that that's not super comforting for a
lot of people but you know it like I
said it's it's the same reason that
people come up with conspiracy theories
because it's like they want [__] to make
sense I get it I get it but [__] doesn't
make sense it just doesn't um and I
think that people would be better served
by just realizing that and just kind of
like I don't know if it makes it easier
to deal with I don't think it does but
just knowing that look anything bad
could happen to anybody at any time it
doesn't matter how famous they are it
doesn't matter how awesome they are it
doesn't matter you know anybody could
just be like taken away from you at any
moment and honestly I kind of feel like
that makes you appreciate life more
because you realize that there's no
reason there's no reason it doesn't mean
oh this person's bad and it's like bad
[__] happens them or something like that
it's there's no thought behind it well
point of view the the universe might
have a certain reason for a plan they do
but I plan just doubt it it it doesn't
seem that way it could be some people
appear just to do certain things and
they leave and they become something
else later on so but you just have to
develop like a kind of Zen about it yeah
yeah yeah just you can't worry about it
in in normal
life because you don't have any control
overol and you don't have a full view of
what's Happening which I think is
another thing that people because people
do like to have control over there which
like I get it I I like to have that too
but it's like you don't really right um
You don't have a lot of control over
stuff and I'm not saying you should just
like lay back and let [__] happen like
don't do that because you can like
affect things but don't worry too much
about [__] that you can't control
because a lot of [__] is outside of your
control Steve Morris he says at the best
do your best and don't
worry I mean I think that's good at T
you don't worry about it because you
have nothing else you can do there
literally is nothing else you can do all
you can do is just just be the best
person you can
be do as good as you can do do do the
best you can it given the circumstances
and just try not to worry too much about
it because there's a lot of [__] that's
outside of your
and you can't do about it yeah and
ultimately eventually you'll die
be everyone everyone will um I love this
everybody does I love this Nicholas says
where did I where did I find it was it
really that far back did I lose it that
far
back [__] I lost it I thought you were
laughing what I saw this and now I can't
see
it I lost
it I lost it oh Nicholas says Tom is
over here talking about a quantum
afterlife while wearing a baby's onesie
[__] right it's not a baby's onesies
it's
two two it's not technically a don't do
that it's not technically a onesie just
doing that [__]
right he decided to just wear his I was
wearing my sexual cloth my work clothes
man we [__] streaming on stream was
streaming in that we well I had I had I
just put a shirt on over it cuz I
thought it was a little much yeah you
put a shirt on over that I did yeah oh
okay you sure did no that's that's not
how that's not how that [__] worked
before but how that [__] worked before
that [__] I thought you would complain
earlier I didn't notice it I didn't
notice it this sh [__] oh man never
mind he's gonna make me wear this outfit
out on Friday night I'm GNA make you no
you well you're not gonna make me yeah
it did look good oh it looks great like
I said I got into a course that I hadn't
gotten into for like a couple give him a
side shot give him a side sh so I'm like
stand straight put your arm back look at
look at this [__] [__] I'm not I'm not
going to take it out I'm going to take
it I'm not going to take it out just F
oh my
God it's like a [__] it's like a deck
of an aircraft carrier you could [__]
you could land Jets
across all right you g land Jets you
land Jets across that that's right he's
like pulling it all down [__] I don't
know like I said I thought it was a
little more she got some big ass boobs I
know well what do you want me to do
about it I I know you do I know you love
yeah I know you love him
I'm gonna go ahead and make an
announcement now what yeah tell me just
whisper me and Jen me and Jenna getting
married tomorrow
a I didn't know if you were going to say
yeah okay we're getting married tomorrow
I thought we were waiting till Friday to
say we we'll talk about it later all
right go time father I didn't know you
might I thought well he might get drunk
and just like kind of s because we were
gonna wait till Friday yeah we've been
good 13 years tell man if anything
happens to me she's gonna be stuck out
yeah I'm be h so ahead and get the
paperwork done yeah can I say like we
went yeah to the courthouse on Monday
and we filled out the you have to do the
LI the the thing for the license yeah
and in Florida this is not how it used
to be because I got married in Florida
back in the 90s and I didn't have to do
this but you have to fill out the
paperwork for the license and then you
either have to take a
class like a 4H hour class that you have
to pay for by the way yeah um which I
don't even know what the class entails
and I was like I'm not taking a class
I'm like 50 something [__] off um or you
have to wait three days before you can
so talking about a class this is well
we've been together for 13 years like
what we told the girls like we don't
need a class we didn't a class we've
been together 13 years we're like in our
50s and we've been together a long time
it's like we don't need a [__] class
and it's like I'm not doing that and I'm
not paying for it um um they do give you
a discount if you take the class but I
was like still but if you don't take the
class you have to wait three days yes in
between getting the license and actually
doing the thing and so I was just kind
of like that seems dumb but all right I
don't know whose idea that was it wasn't
like that back in the 90s we're just
going to do the thing it's a secular
thing you know what I mean and then
later we're GNA have a big party and
we're just then we're GNA announce it
but you guys got the sneak peek we
probably I didn't think he was going to
say it proba do cuz that's why I said
are you saying it's G happen tomorrow
anyway are you saying it yeah we're
going by the time by the time the [__]
leaks out to any family members [__]
we'll we it been done anyway well that
was our that was our conc we just want
certain family members get involved we
don't we don't want people finding out
until after we've already done it yeah
some of you some of you guys might know
it's like sorry it's a done deal like
you can't do anything about you can't
interfere we're gonna have a big party
Friday at the club well either this
Friday or the next one
because I asked well I I wrote to
Dimitri and I was like well when's the
next momento Mory after this one because
there's one coming up on Friday night
because we wanted to do like a party
there okay and he never told me because
he got so
excited yeah that we were actually doing
it that I don't think he ever told me
what the next one was I thought the next
one was the 29th but I guess not I don't
know all right I don't know but that's
kind of when we were going to month
before payday yeah [__] crazy I mean
I well I don't know we get checks all
time I don't know if that's when it is
or not but yeah it's weird because and
we're gonna do a thing to [__] uh
collect up some damn [__] wedding
gifts from yall to what do they call
that [__] but like a registry yeah I
didn't even think about that until
Demitri like I asked him I like when's
the next momento because we want to and
I told him and he's like oh my God you
guys should do a registry like everybody
would give me money I'm like I don't
think they would but yeah I didn't even
think about that we'll do one and I was
like well I might do a [__] one I
did actually like go on um what was it
the knot yeah that's like the big
wedding website and they have like a
like one and I was like yeah I guess
I'll set up put that out but I don't
know I'm not like that worried about it
but um I didn't even think of it until
he said something because honestly you
didn't even say anything about it until
this past weekend yeah and then suddenly
we're at the coffee shop and then he
just starts like talking about it and
I'm like are you [__] serious right
now because well I've been thinking
about it for about a year oh you didn't
tell me yeah I thought you didn't want
to I thought you didn't want to I don't
know whatever gave you that idea years
back I said wead get married I ain't
married you well yeah because I was so
mad that you took so long to ask
me like all right that just out of spite
I was like trying just trying to give
you some benefits in case anything
happens to me well yeah that's what I
was but yeah but I was mad because you
waited so long that's I I think that's
what it was so I was like I was being
spiteful about it that's how these
chicks do that's how these chicks do but
see and you even said the other day at
the restaurant you were like well [__]
we probably should have done it like
five or six years in and then we could
have had all those benefits all that
time and I was like yeah exactly yeah
but you got to look back at time and see
what was going on at that timeing there
there was It was kind of tumultuous off
and on not all us just the outside world
too was happening and we're like [__]
you know you didn't know what was going
you didn't know what was going to happen
so I was actually now it's pretty much
kind of set on set Stone what's going to
happen so I was like kind of surprised
like when you brought it up but I you
know like you said it's like look we've
been together such a long time it's like
you know doesn't really make sense
you're not going anywhere I'm not going
anywhere we hit the dating Market what's
going to happen [__] I told him I was
like man if something happened to you
I'm just giving up on this [__] it's
like why would I want that probably the
same for me too I'd be like yeah I'd
want that I wouldn't want that
aggravation yeah kind of old you know
yeah well not even just that it's just
it's just too much trouble
it's not worth it it's not worth the ort
you know what I mean it's just not like
trying to like meet a new person and
getting all that we're getting so much
out of this why we really want to change
it up that's what I mean yeah I told you
yeah if i' wanted to [__] off I would
have done it a long time ago I would
have done a long time
ago if I'm G to get married in on oh my
God how funny would that be I'm [__]
I'm going [__] get married in a strap
on had a big old [__] strap on with a
Halo over my head and I'll be wearing
[__] I would give you money if flops
and a and a light coat of body
oil look a light coat of body he's very
specific about that that gleam and
glisten that's nice
yeah Camp guy said awesome my own
daughter just got married at the
courthouse about a month ago both she
and her new husband are licensed
registered nurses see that's cool we got
to have a party just to family get
together yeah what we're we were just
going to do it like I said we're going
to like do we were going to do on the
down low yeah cuz we're going tomorrow
we're going have a party at the club and
then yeah because like I mean honestly
be there
anyway that's kind of all our people
that we've been hanging out with so long
and I and that's what I told Demetri I
said we kind of want to like celebrate
with you guys like all y'all so uh so we
were probably going to do that but we'll
see how it works out like I said we'll
probably go tomorrow we went Monday and
got all the paperwork filed for the
license so tomorrow we can go and do the
thing yeah and we'll see how it goes
yeah we we'll go up and get some Chinese
food too well yeah I mean obviously
because it's RIS like it's like three
miles down the street yeah we did that
last time too like we went and filled
out the paperwork Town's like where's
Ichibon from here I was like oh it's
only like three miles like up the street
he's like oh we're going there so that's
what we always end up eating but uh but
yeah uh Tammy said is Tom gonna get
pegged on the honeymoon man y all are
[__]
nasty yall are nasty actually on the
honey but we're probably going to make a
[__] erotic video we probably will
yeah you know how you know how we do
that should have probably be in public I
have her in a [__] bridal gown and
[__] we'll be in we'll be in a [__]
we'll be in a [__] parking we'll be
in a be in a parking structure I got her
[__] ass laid out across the hood a
car people walking by I'm [__] just
nailing the [__] out of her titties
hanging over the [__] side oh my God
you love that yeah hell yeah there's a
whole sub genre of porn because we were
watching some of it earlier
of uh bachelorette party gone horribly
wrong and it's just like a whole thing
with like it's it's set up the way it's
formatted it's just that somebody like
it's um a a bride to be that is texting
her uh fiance her groom to be and it's
like hey we're at the bachelorette party
blah blah blah custom but yeah but then
like as long as the night goes on it's
kind of like and then in the end spoiler
alert they all get gangbanged by a bunch
of black dudes by black dudes yeah and
they keep sending pictures she sended
pictures to the husband and he's like
what the [__] yeah her and all her
friends they're so funny [__]
hilarious I love that there's this whole
sub like said like said in the picture
and like well at first at first it's her
friends sending the pictures and then
she gets drunk enough that she sends the
pictures to I'm just like oh my God
that's funny funny is that it's made up
of clips of [__] just stock photos
of like people in bridal gowns like
getting yeah it's it's so funny with
written text there they're so funny I
was like o there's it's a whole like
roller coas of a story happening then it
ends in like amate amateur footage is
the [__] BBC gang bangs and [__]
she's in a [__] rattle gown hilarious
so funny Mind Games man I'm not doing a
b porn is about mind games I'm not doing
a baset party those are dumb yeah I
don't I don't I don't really like that
whole we're too old for that yeah I'm
too old for that and it's it's like even
when I was younger it's like it just
seemed like I don't know pointless
that's that [__] that's that [__] people
in their 20s yeah that's some like I
don't know I don't like that kind of
[__] but yeah so now you guys know but
[__] every night of our life when we
go out is like a bachelor R party what
are you talking about pretty well what I
don't get gangbanged by dud no but that
what that's how you imag literally never
happened a bachelorette parties by
getting gang banged no well in porn it
is in porn it is but not in real life
most of them are probably really boring
it's just like you know the girls all go
out and it's like woo they have a
stripper or something they all get
shitfaced and then like pass out and
throw up yeah that's pretty much what
usually happens stripper stripper's in
he's in and out of there [__] in
about an hour yeah he's like look it's
my job hey look at my di wo and yeah
yall are too fat I gotta get out of here
really yall are
fat well you know you got to make it fun
you got to make it fun for but uh yeah I
don't think I don't think Tom's getting
pegged on the honeymoon y the
ridiculous we'll see no man my virginity
is worth a [__] [__] ton of money man
it's worth a [__] ton you're going have
to [__] raise like [__]
20,000 I'm talking about motorcycle
maybe I should motorcycle maybe I should
add that to the registry no it'll never
happen it'll Tom's pegging it'll never
happen it'll never happen oh my God I
totally might do that it'll never happen
I'm an [__] like that you think I
should it's just going to be it'll never
happen it'll never that's got to be
motor cycle man it's be work like a
Harley
man you never know you never know how
that'll turn out that sh never I'm
totally adding that these women man
they're fantasies I know we're the
worst women and their aren't we terrible
terrible we're terrible Nicholas says
congrats by the way I've been a fan
since the early double digit episodes oh
[__] really yeah wow like I said I still
can't believe it it's like so weird it's
so
surreal I just never thought it was
going to happen Victor says thank you
Victor Tom's pegging fun see already
[__] I knew if I said something about it
[__] you [__] I knew if I said
something about it but people were give
me money for
that but everyone's probably going to
need photographic evidence which I will
provide I'm I'm not averse to that I'm
just [__] with you Tom I would never
do anything against your
will like what the [__] was that like
but I took the video of you and I says
we're working doing a show what when was
that a few minutes ago oh remember oh
that was this show yeah yeah yeah what
the [__] was that what was I doing
nothing just doing a show talking oh
okay why she's like why are you sending
me a video of for talking she didn't
know what it was oh right yeah she
doesn't watch our show I guess no she
doesn't know anything about the show I
thought we told her yeah oh no no no we
haven't seen her that much yeah
Sebastian said Tom's got to have a stag
night and Jenny had night yeah that's
the British terminology
like I said I never really saw I never I
don't know doesn't sound like that fun
to me I have like a lot of you know
friends that are girls that I would hang
out with but I
don't I don't want to go see strippers
or nothing like that sounds kind of
boring wouldn't mind go out and getting
shitfaced last time me and Jen went to
the [__] strip club we were the
[__] center of attention strip
strippers are all over her oh my God
strippers love me
yeah I think strippers love when any
when a woman shows up yeah I guess so
cuz they're just kind of like oh my God
thank God it's like not a drooling
weirdo talking about these dudes yeah
yeah I got all I got all the Scuttle
butt yeah because they just wanted they
just wanted a sympathetic ear yeah and I
was just and I was there to provide it
yeah you know mean they asked us to come
back they did we sh one of these days
yeah they probably they probably don't
work they probably don't work that was a
long time ago but yeah that's a fun
place actually that's a it's a pretty
Swanky they got a they got they serve
steaks and everything yeah it's got a
real good food it's called Rachel's yeah
in Orlando it's famous it's been here
for like forever I don't even remember
it's like going to Vegas yeah it's nice
in there it's massive it's got a super
good [__] Buffet MH you go there and
you pay we had go just for the buffet
one of these days they got a bike night
and everything maybe we'll do that for
that any yeah women aren't allowed in
there unless they're accompanied by a
guy yeah but so you know they don't like
single women coming in there because you
they don't know if they're hookers or
whatever you know but
um no if a guy takes a woman in there
[__] the [__] chick trip the [__]
out especially if you we were go we were
goed out too we love that [__] yeah they
thought that was awesome yeah well
because like I said you know that we're
not giving dances giving her dances and
[__] [__] I know I got I don't think
we gave me any money no they were
complaining I didn't then they were
complaining complaining about the
[__] work
schedule remember that yeah complain
about these that's what I mean they were
like talking [__] you know I was like
dude I feel your pain no seriously well
they just wanted somebody to listen to
them yeah that's all I'll listen these
dudes don't want to tip they just want
to [__] I don't want [__] the kind of
[__] they well now that we've done
stream we know what they're talking they
want it's kind of the same thing
everybody just wants like sh [__]
these dudes every Everybody Wants
shipper free yeah same kind of [__] that
happens we we're dealing with it
also helping these [__] jack
off but they got a pay like I said yeah
oh should we say what's that we had our
favorite client K came back he came back
last night yeah we've talked about him
before yeah he was this [__]
redheaded dude he shredded his [__] and
he's a lot of fun yeah and every time he
[__] he turns his camera on he
[__] he spends money he came back
last night yeah he came back yeah yeah
[__] and he was like where have you
guys been yeah you I was like a we were
kind of like sporadic because it was
like part time but he must have done
about close to 20 minutes huh 15 minutes
with something like that yeah yeah we
had a whole at 799 a minute 6.99 a
minute yeah 699 a minute okay but yeah I
was like I was happy to see him again I
was like come back come back all you
want we told him about this
show well no he's a good dude I like
that I like that D we told him to send a
private message we'll tell him where how
to find the show he likes to do like a
it's all it's like a virtual threesome
kind of yeah yeah yeah he puts on a show
for us yeah like he wants to pretend
like he's here he's involved yeah yeah
right he says we're having threesome
we're having threesome right so it's
like Tom uses the camera handles and
stuff wingman I'm the camera and
everything like that he's going oh this
is
awesome yeah so he's one of our favorite
kinds yeah actually he's funny he's like
the best one he's like the one we
remember probably about 25 26 probably
maybe he might be a little bit older I
can't really tell what's that I can't
really tell I think he's about 25
between 25 and 30
yeah it's hard to find an older
good-look couple yeah yeah is it I guess
it must be yeah when you well we've seen
some of the other couples on there and
some of them are super hot I'm not yeah
the younger ones but some of the older
ones are kind of yeah you'll find out
guys this is I know some of you dudes
maybe you're not really [__] too hard
in the game especially if you're younger
when I was in my
20s you couldn't compete against the
guys in your 30s you could be cute as
[__] you weren't going to you can get
laid you won't be able to keep them cuz
the guy in his 30s has a lot more to
offer a woman in her
swanes okay a lot more stability all
right uh but the thing is those as you
age either guy or a woman in in today's
economy the older you are and the better
looking you are the more of a rarity you
are so actually if you're doing
something like what we do your value
goes
up if you're a guy who's 55 he's put
together together well and he's got some
security man your value goes way up
because all the good guys at 55 are
taken yeah they've all been married so
you you become kind of like a
unicorn
and a 50 five year old woman would be
all about me but I wouldn't [__] be
interested in that if I was single
because I could get a woman that was
35 you know which would be better for me
because everybody's doing what's best
for them
doesn't have any to do with what's best
for you you
know so and it's the same thing with
women a 50-year-old woman and she's
[__] hot like I showed her a woman we
have locally here Nam is [__] um
Lauren Lopez she's 55 she's my
age and she's been a fitness trainer for
24 years and her and her husband do fans
Le and only
fans they make good money doing that
because women at 55 don't look like her
and she's gorgeous I can show you guys
yeah her Instagram and I told Jen I said
this is the actually probably the way
you're going to look because Jen's in
training right now and of course she's
on hormone
replacement and um because if you're not
on home home R room replacement after
[__] 35 or 40 you won't see much
results but
um and I will say this one that I'm on
now she massive yeah the ones before
didn't really do much but this one is
doing a lot yeah 19 North testosterone
none it's made a huge difference yeah
[__] very effective but the thing is
is I just went by the book I went
through the DHT well you know that's
just what we had to do it's like
everybody's different so you have to
kind
of you know
okay all right here's
Lauren this chick
it's
55 so it can be done yeah I'll show you
some
more and then she's got two
kids there she is lifting she's not
natural though she's on
stuff but that's what it takes at that
age she lives here in
Florida old [__] like me old [__]
looking good and I'll tell you
what a woman at 55 that looks like that
is in very high demand young guys love
it they love it I have noticed that yeah
on streammate because a lot of uh people
that come in are like yeah there's
younger dudes yeah a lot of younger guys
like women like that because you know
and [__] some of our some of our
subscribers
here you know who are open with me
[__] who are friends about talk about
what what a crush they have on Jan I'm
not going to name any names and it's
guys in their 30s and it's because the
generational differences a lot of the
young women that are in their 20s and
30s right now are just kind of
like you can't they're not they're
wishy-washy you can't they can't really
trust them I don't want to say it's
mommy issues it's just that [__]
older women are reliable and more
friendly and well we have our sh more
reliable yeah you know they're just well
it's just kind of the same the other way
around it's just kind of like you know
people want to be with people that have
their [__] together yeah nobody really
wants to be with somebody that's going
to be so to you women out there who are
older there's a lot of younger guys if
you [__] give them a chance yeah you
they'll date you they might even live
with you they may not marry you but
people but a lot of people aren't
getting married today you know what I
mean just just different situation it's
different
now
um but the thing is though is if you're
if you're over 40 you got to look good
you got to look great because and the
better you look the more rare you are
and the more action you're going to get
from these young guys well like I said
as long as I I'm kind of like anybody
that looks like they have their [__]
together yeah if you look like every
[__] together that it doesn't really
matter like now that girl that woman I
showed you Lauren her husband I guess
it's her husband I've seen a pictures
some they they do the
[__] fley and fley together name is
Lauren
Lopez her husband um is a bodybuilder he
look good you know uh he's no slouch
either and he's in his
50s he might be a little bit younger
than
her
but if he wasn't
around Lauren would probably be a dude
with with a dude in his [__] mid-30s
maybe
40s you know because because she can do
it and when you look at the statistics
she'd be top 1% top 1% of somebody in
their 50s
easily but it doesn't take much to get
in the top 1% an
effort you had to have a good history
behind you where you weren't [__]
eating yourself to death and [__] and
abusing your
body and you had decent genetics you
know even average genetics at 55 a woman
can look really good if she puts a work
in part of the work is knowing
understanding science
biochemistry because you're going to
need
supplementation that's all I'm G to say
about it going on too long that's okay
joh yeah that's okay yeah it's 11 o'
yeah we got to we got to go to the
courthouse tomorrow
yeah I still know I don't know what I'm
going to wear yeah I got to figure
something out but look at that look at
that look at that that girl's 55 all I
can see is a ring hold on
yeah that's a butt
yeah okay you know
yeah that's possible you made everything
blurry
okay it is like I said you just got to
keep your [__] together yeah got to keep
your [__] together okay all right go
ahead and shut it down okay we mostly
talked about the topic right oh yeah we
talked about the topic in depth okay
that's good sometimes I forget yeah
because we go off on so many tangents no
it's fully done but yeah so we'll be
back on Friday for the Sidetrack show
where we can talk more fully about this
kind of stuff
because should be a done deal by that
time right yeah yeah when we do the show
on Friday yeah so we'll talk about that
we'll see how it goes uh but yeah we'll
see you guys again on Friday hopefully
you guys can all join us thank you very
much Victor uh for sending us the super
chats yeah and we'll see you guys again
on Friday night my onesie oh and there's
a on your baby onesie there's not a
onesie
on oh my
God oh my God all right so on that note
we'll see you guys on Friday good